Das war's für heute. Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen und bis zum nächsten Mal!
So Leute, ich bin auch mal wieder da.
Relativ spontane Entscheidung jetzt gewesen, Stream anzumachen.
Aber ich hab gesehen, wir haben Prime Day bzw. das hab ich schon vor ein paar Stunden gesehen.
Aber ich dachte mir, wir können uns das mal zusammen angucken, um wieder festzustellen, dass es nichts gibt.
Ich wette mit euch, es gibt wieder nichts.
Es gibt ganz viel Amazon-Geräte und es gibt ganz viel Zeug, wo du noch nie was von gehört hast und was keiner braucht.
Aber nichts, was ich haben will.
Warte jetzt erst mal, bis der Stream richtig angelaufen ist.
Weil aktuell sind acht Leute da, das sind wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Ammo-Box-Camper oder so, die noch das Tab auf hatten seit gestern.
Jetzt hat Twitch mitgekriegt, dass der Stream online ist.
Das sage ich zwar, vor einer Stunde schon da sehe ich gerade im Chat null.
Wicked Clown 475, danke schön.
Massive Prime Subscriptions hier wieder.
Nice.
Moin Leute.
Ja, ich wette mit euch, es gibt wieder nur Müll beim Prime Day.
Gibt wieder gar nichts.
Werden wir jetzt gleich überprüfen.
Aber ich wette mit euch, es gibt wieder nur Müll.
Amazon-Geräte gibt es wahrscheinlich in Massen.
Es gibt irgendwie so komische Ring Doorbells und so ein Kram, was ich mir im Leben nicht hinstellen würde.
Ganz viel billiger China-Chinesen-Kram.
Tausend Kleinteilsachen, die keiner haben will.
Von Socken bis Kosmetik-Dinger, wo ich nicht mehr weiß, was es ist.
Wieder richtig viel sinnloses Zeug.
Hat mir heute das mit dem Arbeitsamt reingezogen.
Du meinst das Video, das von 2012 oder das Aktuelle?
Das ist das halbwegs Aktuelle.
Das Alte?
Ja, ich habe das nochmal neu aufgenommen und ein bisschen mehr drumherum erzählt.
Das ist glaube ich erst ein Jahr her oder so.
Also wenn du das mit Black Ops 2 Gameplay oder so im Hintergrund meinst von 2012, das ist schon wirklich alt.
Oh, erinnere mich nicht daran.
Das Alte wird von YouTube empfohlen.
Leute, YouTube empfiehlt aktuell ziemlich viel Blödsinn von mir, habe ich gesehen.
Beispielsweise auch MW3 Gameplays.
Ich mir auch denke, warum empfiehlt das MW3 Gameplays?
Wo ich die ganze Runde in irgendwie drei Wege laufe und mich mit dem Controller kaum bewegen kann richtig.
Und mit übelster Kack-Audio-Qualität am Start bin.
Naja, aber gut, wenn YouTube das so macht.
Ich will mich jetzt ja nicht beschweren, dass irgendwelche Videos von mir empfohlen werden.
Das hier ist der ASMR-Stream, den du dir vorstellen kannst.
Guck, ich kann Twitch-Emotes ASMR machen.
Bunkers, Bunker-Shake, Bunkers.
Ah, ja, ja.
Massive ASMR, ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das überhaupt hört durch den Filter hier.
Das klingt zu aggressiv.
Ja, ich bin halt nicht so der nice ASMR-Whisperer.
Was die auch immer machen, die erzählen dann sowas, wenn ich was gucke, dann eigentlich ausschließlich englischsprachige Channels.
Die erzählen dann irgendwie so ultra-random Zeug immer.
So total, teilweise zusammengewürfeltes Zeug.
Und zwischendurch kommen sie dann hin, so nach dem Motto, und jetzt einige Crinkle-Sounds.
Und dann haben sie dann eher komisches Plastik am Start.
Hey, danke schön für den... Ah, nee, nee, Timeout, Kekl, sieht fast genauso aus.
Aber NXL hat subscribt, sieben Monate, danke schön für den Sub.
Warum hast du eigentlich erst sieben Monate, dich gibt es hier schon seit drei Jahren oder so auf dem Channel?
Erst mal Sub, wie heißt das, wie könnte man das denn, Sub-Shaming? Warum hast du nur so wenig subscribt?
Aber schön, dass du am Start bist, sieben Monate sind auch leise.
Ich meine, das ist immerhin der Diamant-Keks, ja.
Du bist doch schon ewig am Start hier, oder? Der Name sagt mir was.
Du hast doch schon weit über tausend Messages geschrieben.
Wobei, das stimmt überhaupt nicht. Das stimmt nicht.
Du folgst seit 2001, äh, seit 2021 tatsächlich erst.
Ich hätte gedacht, du bist länger da.
Das muss jetzt überprüft werden.
Ja, tatsächlich.
Lul.
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Tatsächlich. Na gut.
Small Access Point ist auch am Start.
Ja, das kann sein.
Wenn du auf Twitter öfters mal am Start bist, das ist möglich.
Ja, also die Sachen genau zuordnen.
Also sprich, wo ich jetzt was wie gesehen habe, stimmt.
Neue Exchange-Sicherheitsupdates sind draußen fixen, aber die neuesten Zero Days nicht.
Die neuesten Zero Days, ist das irgendwie...
Wie ist das irgendwas mit Shell oder so?
Hab ich vorhin gelesen, Hoax Shell oder sowas?
Ist das das?
Windows Reverse Shell currently undetected by Microsoft Defender.
Ich hab nur vorhin kurz was gelesen auf einer der einschlägigen Hacker-Seiten.
Für die Daily Hacking Doses.
Danach hab ich gleich noch Hacker News gelesen.
Dann hab ich mein Hoodie aufgesetzt und bin in den Keller.
Da bin ich erst vor 5 Minuten wieder hochgekommen und hab mir gedacht, jetzt kann ich Stream anmachen.
Stimmt, stimmt, ja das kann sein.
Jetzt wo du es sagst.
Ja, ja, ich glaub daher kenn ich das.
Ganz im Ernst?
Es gibt viele ASMR-Videos, die sind Müll.
Was ich auch nicht verstehe, wie sich das jemand angucken kann.
Aber es ist halt so vielfältig, was die Leute toll finden und was nicht.
Dass ich es irgendwie...
Dass es mir schwer fällt dazu zu sagen, es ist Müll, aber es ist viel Müll dabei.
Wisst ihr was ich am allerschlimmsten finde?
Sie sind die ganzen Weiber, die irgendwelche Ear-Licking-Sounds machen oder sowas.
Das finde ich richtig abartig.
Und da weiß ich immer nicht, gucken das die Leute, weil die das entspannt?
Oder gucken das die Leute, weil sie die geil finden?
Das passt ja eigentlich nicht so genau zusammen.
Ansonsten es gibt doch schon angenehme Videos.
Du liest jeden Tag die Hacker-News?
Ich auch.
Bester.
Hacker-News.
Why Combinator?
Beste.
Sieht zwar aus wie von 1995, ist es aber nicht.
Oh, Flashback, Alter.
Hast du Tipps zum Programmieren lernen?
Ja, ich habe einige Tipps, nachdem das hier immer auch schon ein Thema ist im Stream.
Es ist immer schwierig was aus dem Ärmel zu schütteln.
Überleg dir am besten, was du machen willst, in welcher Richtung.
Also einfach sagen, ich programmiere jetzt, ohne zu wissen in welcher Richtung man was machen will, ist schwierig.
Und wenn du gar keine Ahnung hast, dann fang mit JavaScript an und bastel ein bisschen im Browser rum.
Ansonsten ist es natürlich ungemein hilfreich, wenn du irgendwas schon im Kopf hast, was du machen willst.
Weil dann ist es einfacher was rauszufinden.
Oh Leute, ich habe voll meinen Poppers platt gesessen.
Ich glaube, mein Hintern ist eingeschlafen auf der einen Seite.
So, ja, dann schauen wir mal bei Amazon.
In welchem Browser machen wir das auf?
Ich würde sagen, wir machen noch mal einen extra, ne, wir brauchen mehr Tabs.
Was schaust du dir so an, an ASMR?
Lass mal überlegen.
Also der beste Channel, der leider sehr inaktiv ist, aber der finde ich beste Channel, ist diese eine Australier.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Nicht die Grills.
WTF?
Das da?
Der da, das ist der beste.
Ohne Scheiß, beste ASMR Channel.
Der Dude, der ist leider sehr inaktiv.
Warum sollte ich meine Tabs zumachen?
Sekunde, Leute, ich muss mal kurz etwas, ein bisschen was entspannendes anmachen.
Ja, das ist deutlich entspannender.
Ja, genau, warum sollte man RAM freigeben?
Guck mal.
Ich habe 32 GB RAM und nur 7 belegt.
Unbenutzter RAM ist verschenkter RAM.
Guck nur.
Ja, ich suche ein paar bestimmte Sachen, aber ich glaube nicht, dass es die beim Prime Day gibt.
Was ist dein Rekord bei offenen Tabs im Browser?
Man zählt die ja selten.
Also ich zähle ja nicht alle meine Tabs, bevor ich irgendwie mal was zumache.
Also ich weiß nicht, was ich am meisten auf, was das meiste war.
Ich habe Overwatch immer noch nicht runtergeladen.
Ich habe auch wirklich keinen Hang dazu.
Ich habe damals Overwatch 24-7 quasi gefühlt gegrindet und tausende Stunden in das Game
rein.
Ich hatte ja schon über 1000 Stunden an einer Beta oder so voll gestört.
Ich war irgendwie level 390 oder so in einer Beta.
Total bescheuert.
Naja, zumindest nachdem Blizzard das so gegen die Wand gefahren hat, irgendwie habe ich
auch keinen Bock auf Overwatch.
Leute, ich habe eine Anfrage bekommen von einem Handy-Game.
Ja, naja, ja, ich war ganz gut, ganz, ganz brauchbar, sagen wir mal.
Es hat mir ja sehr geschmeichelt, dass manche gesagt haben damals, es wurden ja ein paar
Matches von uns gecastet damals sogar und dass die dann teilweise gesagt haben, so die
Pros, wo ich mir gedacht habe, Alter, dass mich mal jemand Pro nennt, mit meinen damals
auch irgendwie 33 oder so, Alter.
Ja, fand ich schon sehr schmeichelhaft.
Ich war nie super überragend gut.
Also das Einzige, was ich geschafft habe, ist Top.
Wofür gab es das Abzeichen?
Top 500, glaube ich, bei Overwatch.
Season 1 Top 500 habe ich noch gepackt.
Und danach habe ich eigentlich gar nicht mehr so viel gespielt.
Oh, frag nicht, frag nicht.
Das hat keinen tieferen Sinn.
Ja, und deswegen irgendwie habe ich keinen Bock mehr auf Overwatch.
Ich habe das ja noch lange Zeit öfters ab und zu mal gespielt und auch immer mal ein
bisschen so geguckt, was passiert in dem Game.
Aber Blizzard hat es einfach so lange auf Sparflamme laufen lassen.
Ich finde auch die ganze Overwatch League und das System dahinter ziemlich, ziemlich
müllig.
Gucke ich auch nicht mehr spätestens als nicht mehr auf Twitches, habe ich nicht einen
Match mehr geguckt.
Ich habe vorläufige Benchmarks gesehen, da war die irgendwie 70 Prozent schneller als
in 30 90.
Weiß ich, hat sich das jetzt bestätigt?
Gibt es da was?
Computer Base hat meistens ganz gute Sachen, wenn es um sowas geht.
Radial schnell, auch mit weniger TDB und ohne DLSS3.
Preis-Leistungsverhältnis am Ende einer Generation.
Können wir uns dann angucken, was sagt denn Wolfgang Andermar dazu?
Der weiß es.
Computer Base, gucke ich immer gerne, zeigt mal hier Benchmarks.
Mit und ohne Ray Tracing, Ray Tracing juckt mich so überhaupt nicht.
Leute, wisst ihr was ich witzig finde?
Benchmarks in 1080p macht einfach niemand mehr.
Ist auch total unsinnig eigentlich, weil die Grafikkarten sind, da macht der Unterschied
dann auch nicht aus.
Aber mich interessiert tatsächlich immer noch 1080p.
Am ehesten interessiert mich da noch 1440, am ehesten noch das.
Das Ding ist aber schon schnell.
Man konnte den Krempel doch irgendwie, warte mal Leute, Flashbang.
Man konnte den Krempel doch umstellen, dass es nicht die absoluten Dinger zeigt, sondern
die.
Ach nee, okay, das ist in Prozent.
Na gut.
Ah nee, FP.
Also der ist schon, ist schon, ist schon ordentlich schnell.
Kannste nix sagen.
Vanguard, keck.
Ich mein, guck mal.
In Vanguard ist das Ding einfach 50, naja, 43% schneller.
Das Alexi-Bexi, oh nee, den kann ich mir nicht angucken.
Das ist schon, das ist schon wirklich.
Okay, es ist Vanguard.
Nehmen wir mal irgendwas, irgendwas anderes Sinnvolles.
Zeig mal her.
Superpunk.
Ja trotzdem, trotzdem.
Das ist immer noch ordentlich schneller.
Und Raytracing ist das, das sind die einzig brauchbaren FPS.
Das haben wir sonst noch zu bieten hier.
God of War, okay, das läuft immer ganz gut.
Das ist schon schnell das Ding.
Da kannst du nix sagen, also das flutscht.
Gachibass.
Sie könnten ja mal CSGO in den Benchmark mit aufnehmen.
Wer knackt zuerst, die 800 FPS.
Alter.
Der Preis ist halt brutal.
Irgendwo hin muss man doch mit seiner Kohle.
Das ist schon, das ist schon heftig, oder?
Das ist das erste Mal spielbar.
Was ist denn das überhaupt für eine Auflösung?
Ist das jetzt schon 5K oder was ist das?
Was ist das für, was ist das für eine Auflösung?
Das ist 11 Head Auflösung, ja ultra, ultra weit.
Also ist schon wirklich saumäßig schnell.
Plender Benchmarks.
Alter, das haut schon rein das Ding, man.
Ist da meine 1080 Ti noch irgendwo dabei?
Nur mal so Just For Fun ist die irgendwo.
Hinterlage ist Absturz.
Ja, das haut schon rein das Teil.
Mal kurz, mal kurz checken.
Macht es eigentlich Sinn, irgendwas anderes als die Fauners Edition zu kaufen?
Nein.
Haben man die Fauners, das wird geil.
Geil ist halt.
Ups.
Es sind irgendwo.
Viel Strom die verbrauchen.
Ah, das ist eine gute Frage.
Lass uns mal kurz gucken, Stromverbrauch.
Bis 600 Watt.
Okay, standardmäßig auf 450 und man kann das standardmäßig,
man kann das dann über irgendeine Software noch hoch machen auf 600 Watt.
Alter.
Also das ist schon ordentlich.
Nvidia.com.
Dede Shop.
Ach, gibt es tatsächlich noch welche zu kaufen?
Erst mal, dass sie nicht ausverg-
Moment, Moment, es gibt noch eine schnellere.
Die Titan sind dann immer so ultra ultra mega teuer.
Es gibt noch, es gibt noch was schnelleres.
Unsinnig.
So, GeForce.
Derzeit nicht verfügbar.
Sag ich doch.
Oh, mit RGB.
Es ist okay, es ist eigentlich nirgends wohl so wirklich lieferbar gerade.
Mal warten, mal abwarten, mal abwarten.
Ach, morgen ist erst Release, okay, okay.
Hallo, Geizhals, please.
40, 90 steht hier noch gar nicht drin.
Na ja, warten wir, warten wir mal ab.
Die haben das hier noch gar nicht, die haben das hier noch gar nicht ergänzt.
Also schnell ist das Ding, da kann man nichts sagen.
Also das in Kombination jetzt mit so einer neuen Ryzen CPU.
Wann stellt dann Intel ihr neuen Krempel vor?
Weiß man das schon?
Die haben doch, die haben doch bestimmt auch irgendwas am Start.
Aber der Stromverbrauch ist heftig.
Also Stromverbrauch ist heftig, Preis ist heftig, Leistung ist aber auch heftig.
Es wird doch Zeit für den 4500 Euro Rechner, glaube ich, im Dezember.
Viermal Stromstecker, ja, von nix kommt nix.
Wie juckt denn das?
Da bist du in Zukunft erst mal safe, ganz ehrlich, ich bin sogar mit meinem aktuellen Rechner noch Zukunft safe.
Ich spiele nur 1080p und der Rechner ist fünf Jahre alt, also der hat es schon mehr als gelohnt.
Easy, einfach mehr Geld behalten als ausgeben und dann Grafikkarte kaufen.
Viel Hilfe, viel Rechner an Tertanschluss.
Wie heißen diese Dinger? CCE oder CEE Stecker oder so?
Diese roten?
Vielleicht brauchst du so einen Anschluss für einen Rechner, CEE.
Muss ich mir einen 1000 Watt Netzteil kaufen für eine 4080?
Nee, für eine 4080 wahrscheinlich nicht.
Und für eine 4090 auch nicht.
Ich meine, du brauchst ja 600 Watt für die Grafikkarte auch nur, wenn du sie übertaktest bzw. das Power Target hoch machst.
Dann kommt noch die CPU dazu.
Also wahrscheinlich bist du mit deinem normalen Netzteil, was du jetzt gerade hast, noch safe.
Wenn es jetzt nicht gerade irgendwie ein 350 Watt Netzteil ist oder so.
Also ich denke mal, ich denke nicht, dass du einen 1000 Watt Netzteil kaufen musst jetzt.
So Amazon, wo sind wir?
Eigentlich hat Amazon mittlerweile ein offizielles Dark Theme.
Wenn nicht, müssen wir das so machen, sonst werde ich blind heute noch.
Der andere Seite.
Oh guck mal.
Oh ganze 4%.
Nice.
Da habe ich ja drauf gewartet.
Endlich kriege ich meinen SSD 4% billiger.
Massive Strongs.
Also ich habe ein 8700K mit einer 1080 TI und das habe ich seit 5 Jahren.
Die 1080 TI habe ich sogar noch einen Ticken länger.
Die hatte ich nämlich schon im alten Rechner drin.
Und der Rechner ist immer noch gut.
Und er spielt immer noch alles ab.
Er spielt ab, das ist der übelste Boomer Satz.
Auf dem kann ich immer noch alles spielen, was ich spielen will.
Wie gesagt, ich habe ja auch nur ein 1080p Monitor.
Wir sind halt 240 FPS lieber als ihre Auflösung.
Aber ich glaube, der nächste logischere Schritt wäre für mich wahrscheinlich auch immer ein bisschen größer am Monitor.
Ach, SLI war schon die letzten Jahre über Mist.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es SLI noch gibt. Gibt es SLI nicht noch?
Es ist aber schon seit Jahren eigentlich totaler Müll gewesen.
Gibt es nicht 1044p mit 240?
Gibt es da nicht was Gescheites an Monitoren schon?
Das ist halt bestimmt teuer wie sauer.
Alter!
Nee, ich will nicht 5120, Mann.
1440p ist okay.
Aber doch nicht 5120, was soll ich denn damit?
Da ist ja mal ein ganzer Schreibtisch voll.
Ja, so war es hier.
Das ist schon die bessere Auflösung.
Und mit wieviel Herz gibt es das?
Hey, das ist quasi der Nachfolger von meinen...
Nee, das ist genau der, den ich gerade habe.
Das ist mein Monitor, den es hier gibt.
Meiner ist das, Leute.
Nicht irgendeiner, der kommt am nächsten DHL und holt ihn ab,
wenn ihn einer bestellt bei Alternate.
Wie viel hat der hier?
270 Herz Panel.
Ja, das wäre durchaus was, womit ich mich anfreunden kann.
1440p, 270 Herz.
Oder warum nicht gleich?
Gibt es 1044p, 360 Herz?
Ich meine, wenn schon Upgrade, dann in your face, oder?
Ein bisschen laut, die Musik gerade.
Gibt es so was?
Also, das ist rock swift.
Die Gugelsuche kannst du voll vergessen.
Ab in den Insie-Modus.
Leute, ich kaufe jetzt garantiert aktuell.
Normalerweise habe ich ja in letzter Zeit
ein bisschen was in meine ETFs gesteckt,
aber die Kurse sind so schlecht
und werden wahrscheinlich sogar noch schlechter werden.
Ich nehme lieber einen Monitor, bevor ich mir ETFs kaufe.
Asus Rock Swift.
Die Namen, Alter.
Ja, die gehen auch bestimmt weiter runter.
Wenn es aktuell weltweit ausschaut,
dann kaufe ich lieber Ende des Jahres ein bisschen was
und kaufe mir vorher einen ordentlichen Monitor.
Aber ganz davon abgesehen, ich kann auch Stonks kaufen
und Monitor kaufen.
So schlimm ist es jetzt auch nicht.
Ok, kostet.
Rock Swift gibt es nicht.
Ok, das muss ich mal kurz checken.
Ok, da gucken wir Amazon.
Monitor.
Ja, Monitore.
Geiz als Beste.
2550.
Genau.
Wie gibt es keine Wiederholrate?
Es gibt keine 360.
Ok, was gibt es denn hier?
Ach nee.
Wer will denn sowas haben?
Die Monitore sind mir zu teuer.
Sicher ist da nichts.
Doch sicher ist, dass ich mir lieber einen neuen Monitor kaufen will.
Aber die Preise sind mir dann noch ein bisschen krass.
Holz.
Ey, Holz ist richtig teuer geworden.
Ist im Prinzip alles richtig teuer geworden.
Grafikkarte für 2K ist günstig.
Ich glaube, es hat hier niemand gesagt.
Grafikkarten sind günstig.
Aber ich brauch keinen neuen Monitor.
Ich habe einen 1080p 240Hz-Monitor.
Einen recht guten.
Also da ist erstmal nicht wirklich akut.
Das kann ich nicht weiter benutzen, das Ding.
Ok, also jetzt zeige ich mal her.
Was haben wir denn bei Amazon?
Ich muss Dark Reader rein machen, sonst halte ich das heute nicht aus.
Also 980 Pro gibt es hier zu kaufen.
2TB.
Tja, brauche ich nicht.
Next.
USB-Sticks.
Tatsächlich USB-Sticks.
Und das sind auch die USB-Sticks, die ich mir gekauft habe, glaube.
Davon könnte ich mir tatsächlich immer wieder einen 3er-Pack kaufen.
Ich muss aber mal kurz gucken, was ich dafür bezahlt habe.
Ich meine, Amazon schreibt da viel, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Vielleicht habe ich sie ja nämlich gekauft und die waren sogar noch billiger.
Weiß ich nicht.
Mal schauen.
USB.
Mach mal Dark Reader in Einstellung auf Hell.
Moment, also was habe ich gekauft?
Zahn-Disc.
Dual-Drive-Lux.
Genau das habe ich gekauft.
So, und da hat es gekostet, als ich es gekauft habe.
21 Euro das Stück.
Tatsächlich, dann lohnt sich das.
Dann Join Prime.
Alter, ich bin hier nicht eingeloggt.
Ja, dann merke ich mir das halt jetzt.
Wo macht man im Dark Reader Heller?
Ach hier, du meinst das hier.
Das interessiert den nicht.
Oh, wir haben die Seite gecrashed, Leute.
Lul.
Oh, oh.
CPU 25 Prozent Auslastung.
Oh, Exit Page.
OK.
Ach so.
Ja, so ist, das ist tatsächlich ganz gut.
Leute, Dark Reader ist verbuggt.
Sobald ich das hier mache, ist es, ist es broken.
Gleich wieder zumachen, sonst kackt die Seite wieder ab.
So, das ist natürlich, das ist tatsächlich angenehmer.
Das ist nicht ganz so krall.
So, also die ganzen SSDs können wir vergessen.
Was haben wir hier zu bieten?
Deal on Computers und Software.
Tools, Aha, Tools und Home Improvement.
Das ist das Richtige für mich.
Da müssen wir gleich gucken.
Kannst du mal öffnen?
Alter, jetzt.
Boah, der Dark Reader, man, der leckt rum wie Sau.
Guckt euch das an.
Das ist doch nicht normal.
Deals for you in...
Was?
Patio?
Pascio?
Lord and God, was ist Pascio?
Hab ich schon nie gehört.
Das know ich nicht.
Oh man, mein Browser ist voll am abkacken.
Guckt euch das an.
Ich kann kaum was anklicken.
Leute, ich muss den Dark Reader ausmachen.
Das ist kaputt.
Das ist einfach komplett, komplett porauken.
Ja, wie gesagt, keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Okay, was haben wir hier zu bieten?
Hair removal.
Das ist mir zu anstrengend.
Ich muss das so machen.
Das ist mir sonst zu hell.
So, ist da irgendwas gescheites dabei?
Konnte man den Krempel nicht mal ordentlich sortieren?
Da gab es doch sonst immer so eine Übersicht.
Muss man da auf alle Deals oder so?
Shop all Deals.
Genau.
So.
Und dann konnte man hier immer normalerweise was anklicken.
Genau.
Also ich suche jetzt mal nach ein paar Sachen.
Und ich hoffe, man kann bei Prime Exclusive dienen.
Also was haben die Shelley-Dinger?
Das wird mich zum Beispiel mal interessieren.
Ach, das heißt Terrasse.
Oh, da wäre ich nie drauf gekommen.
Das sind keine Shellys, was man hier gezeigt kriegt.
Das hat noch nicht mal was damit zu tun.
Aber was, was gibt es denn hier im Smart Home Sektor?
Was zum Teufel?
Warum sind irgendwelche Barbie-Meerjungfrauen dazwischen?
Also die Amazon-Suche ist nur wirklich absolut pepega, oder?
Die Amazon-Suche ist so kaputt und so fail,
dass wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Verschwörungstheoretiker
da reininterpretieren könnten,
dass die wollen uns irgendwelche Signale senden.
Okay, so Boxen brauche ich tatsächlich auch mal wieder.
Aber die sind viel, viel zu teuer.
Suchen wir mal nach hier Junction Box.
Da gibt es welche für den Euro oder 90 Cent oder sowas.
Ja, genau, sowas hier, easy.
Zehn Stück, neun Euro, gutes.
Ja, sowas könnte ich mal wieder gebrauchen.
Weil gerade auch für Microcontroller,
dann zusammen mit ein paar anderen Sensoren irgendwo reingepackt,
die Dinger sind praktisch.
Hol die Dinger auf Reichel, zehn Cent pro Stück, ja noch besser.
Sind das dann aber auch die bisschen größere?
Ach, was soll ich denn hier dann suchen?
Wie heißt das auf Deutsch?
Verteiler-Box wahrscheinlich?
Sag mal dann, was ich suchen soll, keine Ahnung.
Abzweigdose.
Sixhead.
Feuchter Traum, was?
Ach, Feuchtraum, Abzweigdose.
Ich dachte schon.
1,50, kostet auch nur zehn Cent.
Oder sind das zehn Stück?
Teurer.
Ein Stück, 4,25.
Kann man da irgendwie nach...
Wie teuer sind meist 58 bis 100 Watt Netzteile?
Das weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht, aber warum fragst du mich?
Das guckt doch einfach bei Geizhals, was das kostet.
Das weiß ich doch aus dem Kopf nicht.
Du kannst einfach auf Geizhals gehen, gehst da zu Netzteile.
Oder Power Supply oder wo auch immer das genau drinne steht.
Wahrscheinlich unter Hardware.
Netzteil.
Netzteile.
Und dann suchst du dir hier irgendwie sowas raus.
So, sagst du zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung, ab...
Ab 800 Watt, so.
Und dann siehst du, die sind teilweise schon relativ billig.
Und dann kannst du auch so sagen, ab 900 Watt.
Und dann siehst du, die sind immer noch relativ billig.
Okay, das sind aber auch ganz schöne China-Böller hier, oder?
Gute sind sicherlich teurer.
Ich mein, was ist Masked Gaming?
Jemand schon jemals was von Masked Gaming gehört?
Das hört sich an nach LC-Power-China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Zahlmann.
Was ist eigentlich aus Zahlmann geworden?
Könnt ihr euch vielleicht noch dran erinnern?
Zu Zeiten von AMD Atlon XP waren Zahlmann-Kühler das geilste, was es gab.
Irgendwie sind die alle weg.
Das Zahlmann-Ansteckmick gab es auch, ja.
Kennt noch jemand diese Atlon XP Zahlmann-Kupferkühler?
Der da Leute, bester, bester.
Den hatte ich damals.
Atlon XP Zahlmann-Kühler Kupfer.
2003, null.
Das war das Noctur seiner Zeit.
Ich weiß auch nicht, die haben danach nie wieder was auf die Reihe gekriegt, glaube ich.
So, guck mal mal, irgendwie was in Be Quiet.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Be Quiet.
Hab, wie?
Ah nee, die schreibt man ja anders.
Die schreibt man ja Be Quiet, Ausrufezeichen, ja.
Also 140 Euro, kriegst 1000 Watt Be Quiet-Netzteile.
Ganz ehrlich, da kann man nicht meckern, die Dinger taugen.
Und wenn du Glück hast, kriegst du sogar ein Platinum-Rated.
Ist halt die Frage, ob das wirklich dann die Einsparung wert ist.
Weil Netzteile sind halt meistens nur besonders effektiv, wenn sie ansatzweise ein bisschen
Last haben.
Also so mit 10, 15 Prozent Last sind die meisten nicht sonderlich effektiv.
Aber wenn du Platinum-Netzteile hast, gibt es nicht auch noch Titanium-Netzteile?
Moment.
Power Supply, gibt es nicht auch Titanium?
Ja, gibt es auch noch.
Dann ist das definiert, dass das auch beispielsweise bei 10 Prozent Last nicht so viel verbrauchen
darf.
Aber gut.
Oh, die sind, ja, wundert mich, dass man von den X-Men gehört hat.
Aber die Dinger, die gehen.
So, also das würde ich mir eine Runde kaufen.
Eine Runde Verteilerboxen, 10 Stück.
12,99 Euro, dann nehme ich lieber die hier.
Kostet dann einen Euro das Stück, das ist in Ordnung.
Okay, das gibt es als Erste, was ein bisschen aussieht nach Shelley.
Wobei, ganz ehrlich, du musst ja auch kein Be Quiet kaufen.
Bei meinem neuen Rechner kommt ein Seasonic rein.
Aber nur, weil ich noch eins habe.
Da fällt mir allerdings gerade ein, das ist ein 56 Watt-Netzteil, was ich habe von Seasonic.
Das reicht nicht.
Das ist zu wenig, wenn ich meine Grafika davon aufdrehen will.
Also bei mir wird es trotzdem ein Seasonic-Netzteil, ich mag die irgendwie.
Und ihr wisst ja, Rechnerkauf ist wie bei Autokauf, viel Gefühl dabei.
Nehmen kannst du alles, außer es ist ein LC-China-Chinesen-Billig-LC-Power-China-Chinesen-Billig-Ding.
Okay, also die Suche von Amazon hat sich mal wieder rausgestellt als absoluter Crap.
Ist ja immer wieder komplett nicht zu gebrauchen.
Ich hatte letztens das Ding, dass mein Rechner mit 654 nicht mal starten wollte.
Ja, RIP bei der Scanship.
Was zieht denn der beim Einschalten?
Also das müsste, starten müsste das auf jeden Fall.
Tuest du Steam-Profile signen?
Oh Leute, er leckt critical information.
Er leckt richtig viel critical information.
Wir hatten auf dem Discord, ich erklär's dir mal.
Wir hatten auf dem Discord mal einen Channel,
wo man sich eintragen konnte zum Steam-Profile signen.
Und jetzt rate mal von den Leuten, die dort gepostet haben,
wie viele Steam-Profile habe ich denn gesigned, bevor wir den Channel wieder gelöscht haben.
Top 3 oder so.
Ich bin sehr unverlässlich, was sowas angeht.
Das heißt, ich verspreche es gar nicht, weil ich weiß, ich werde es wahrscheinlich eh nicht machen.
Also die Amazon-Suche ist immer so ein Müll.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich tun soll.
Okay, ich gebe jetzt einfach noch ein paar andere Sachen ein, wo ich gucken will.
Ich bin ja schon die ganze Zeit am gucken, ob ich mir nicht doch eine neue USB kaufe.
So, aktuell hatte ich euch ja gezeigt.
Aktuell habe ich so eine USB bei mir im Rack stehen.
Nein.
Aber irgendwas mit 600.
Das Teil.
So einen Teil habe ich aktuell bei mir im Rack stehen.
So.
In die Richtung.
In die Richtung auf jeden Fall.
Das Problem ist, dass man eine USB hat, dass wenn der Strom ausfällt,
dann das Zeug ein paar Minuten überbrückt und dann ist ja der Strom meistens da oder man kann alles runterfahren.
Also eine USB ist ja eigentlich dafür da, dass die Sachen weniger kaputt gehen.
So.
Und ich habe die ja schon ein paar Jahre.
Und eines Morgens ist mein komplettes Rack aus.
Die USB ist aber nicht angeschlossen.
Nee, aktuell nicht.
Nö.
So und eines Morgens ist mein komplettes Rack aus und ich denke mir,
war heute Nacht Stromausfall oder ist Stromausfall und die Batterie leer?
Nein, ist es nicht.
Die Batterie ist verreckt und die ganze USB ist aus.
Und da dachte ich mir so, warum geht eine USB aus, wenn die Batterie verreckt,
obwohl noch der Netzstrom da ist.
Und dann habe ich mich mal ein bisschen schlauer gemacht und dann festgestellt,
das ist anscheinend das Standardverhalten bei Cyberpower.
Batterie defekt, USB geht aus.
Was ist denn das für hirnverbrannter Schwachsinn?
Doch, das ist eine Line Interactive.
Deswegen ergibt es ja noch weniger Sinn.
Und selbst wenn es eine Online-USB ist, dann kannst du da meistens haben die
irgendeinen Bypass oder so drin, weil das letzte was du willst ist.
Wobei, gut, den muss man dann einschalten in irgendwelchen Settings.
Vor allem, die USB ist Hotswap-fähig.
Das heißt, man kann die Batterie rausziehen und tauschen im laufenden Betrieb.
Aber nein, sie geht aus.
Ja, das habe ich gefunden im Internet.
Das ist auch so was halboffizielles.
Und das sackt halt mal richtig.
Ich bin eigentlich nie großer APC-Fan gewesen.
Nicht, weil ich persönlich jetzt selbst daheim schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht habe.
Wir haben einmal auf der Arbeit sehr schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht mit APC-USBs.
Das war aber eine ziemlich alte.
Und man liest halt im Internet nur die Horror-Stories von geplatzten Akkus und sowas.
Aber ganz im Ernst, die ganzen USBs sind alle super billig-Dinger.
So bekommt man das auch mit.
Man will ja von einer USB möglichst wenig mitbekommen.
Und wenn das Ding eine Nachricht sendet oder piepst, wenn die Batterie kaputt ist,
das reicht da voll und ganz.
Die muss ich nicht komplett ausschalten.
Also das ist Müll.
So und Guess, ich dachte mir, das ist vielleicht irgendwie Einstellungs-Sache.
Ich habe gestern mal das Ding an USB gehängt und habe mir diese Power-Panel-Verwaltungs-Software draufgehauen.
Die Software könnten sie sich komplett sparen.
Da kannst du nichts wirklich einstellen.
Das ist komplett sinnlos.
Du kannst ein paar Sachen auslesen, was du auch auf dem Display siehst.
Aber nennenswert einstellen kannst du nichts.
Das Einzige, was du einstellen kannst, ist, glaube ich, bei wieviel Prozent Rest-Akku-Ladung
die Sachen runtergefahren werden.
Das ist alles.
Du hattest eine APC mit einem geplatzten Akku.
Das war so heiß und dick, kaputt, nicht mehr geil.
Tja, das ist scheiße.
Ne, ja doch, die hat auch gepiepst, aber nachdem alles aus war.
Und die Batterie ist verreckt.
Das ist alles ausgegangen, obwohl Netzstrom da war.
Das ist halt ziemlicher Abfuck.
Deswegen mal gucken, was wir so haben.
Also was ich ein bisschen ins Auge gefasst hatte schon, ist nicht Rack-Bauweise, sondern
die haben ja quasi auch was, die Hotswap-fähig sind.
Also die Dinger müssen nicht Hotswap-fähig sein.
Aber ich gehe halt davon aus, wenn eine USB Hotswap-fähig ist, dann verdrägt sie auch,
wenn die Batterie verreckt.
Was die teure APC-USB auf der Arbeit muss man Stromkosten machen für ein Firmware-Update.
Ah, ich wollte gerade sagen, der Satz ergibt keinen Sinn, aber mit Strom los passt das
schon eher.
Wirklich?
Ne, das ist natürlich bescheuert.
Ich wollte jetzt mal kurz gucken.
Die ist viel zu teuer, die sind doch normalerweise viel günstiger.
Was ist das denn für ein GBait?
Das ist doch nicht mal das Aktuelle.
Ja, sowas in der Richtung, sowas in der Richtung.
600 VA reicht dicke aus.
Da ist ja nichts Großartiges dran, es ist ja nicht so.
Als schließe ich da meine RTX 4090 dran an.
Ja, 650 reicht dicke.
Als was arbeitest du?
Also ich habe mal Fachinformatiker-Systemintegration gelernt, 2007.
Und was ich jetzt mache, dazu gibt es jede Menge YouTube-Videos und Stream-Clips und
alles.
Da habe ich mich schon öfters ganz lange drüber ausgelassen.
Ich will jetzt nicht wieder von vorn anfangen.
Aber ich kann es dir kurz, so in einer Minute schnell durchgehen, kann ich dir das erzählen.
Ich arbeite bei einer Bank in Frankfurt als DevOps-Engineer, hört sich wichtig an.
In der Regel sind die meisten Leute, die sowas heute machen, mal früher Linux-Admins gewesen
so wie ich.
Nur, dass ich relativ früh angefangen habe, sogar schon 2011, 2012 rum, mich mit Server-Automatisierung
zu beschäftigen und automatischen Config-Updates und solchen Geschichten.
Und ich habe das quasi bei uns mit eingeführt und seitdem mache ich das.
Bloß, dass ich nebenbei noch ein paar Tools programmiere, so da, wo welche gebraucht werden.
Aber wenn du es genau wissen willst, kannst du dir mal ein Video dazu angucken auf YouTube.
Da habe ich ein Video zugemacht, da, da, da, da erzähle ich dir sogar, was ich verdiene,
wobei das nicht mehr ganz aktuell ist, aber kommt hin.
Also wenn du die zwei Videos anguckst, da weißt du eigentlich ganz gut Bescheid.
Wie lief eigentlich das Video bei ihm?
Zeig mal kurz.
Hey!
Da haben wir richtig viele geguckt, nice.
Fock.
Das ist aber nicht Prime-Angebot aktuell, oder?
Oder warte mal noch, Free Prime Shipping, ja was davon ist denn jetzt angeblich ein
Prime-Angebot?
Moment, jetzt blicke ich den mal durch.
Der hat auch gerade gesagt, dass irgendwelche Dinge in Prime Early Access, ja welche denn,
die da oder was?
Das ist ja das Unsinnigste überhaupt.
Warum sollte ich mir ein altes Modell kaufen, für 150 Euro mehr als das neue Modell und
dann 22% sparen?
Das ist auch nicht nachvollziehbarer Amazon Logik, oder?
Ich kann einfach das neue Modell kaufen, sogar ein besseres, sogar ein besseres und das kostet
bloß 240.
Moment, ich wollte gerade sagen, das sieht falsch aus hier irgendwie.
Ne, 900, guck mal, das ist 900 und das kostet 150 Euro weniger als das andere und billiger.
Hä?
Schwachsinnig.
Also richtiger Blödsinn.
Richtiger Blödsinn.
Richtig unsinnig.
Cringe.
Benenschpend über USB.
So, ne, Kaufschpend ist nix.
Weil, wenn ich Prime kann, ich muss auch so kaufen.
Ich hab doch hier Sachen angeklickt, warum kriegt man die jetzt nicht gezeigt?
Ähm, Schokostecker, ja, das kann tatsächlich sein, aber wer will sowas mit Schokostecker
haben?
Sowieso kein anderes Gehäuse, ja, ich hab, ich hab die letzten, meine letzten drei Rechner
hatten alle Fractal Design Gehäuse, vielleicht wirds diesmal wieder ein anderes, aber die
Sache ist halt die, ich wüsste nicht warum, ich bin, ich bin super zufrieden, ich hab
das Fractal Design seit dem R4 oder so und jetzt, die ganzen generell, aktuell sind die
beim R7 oder R8 oder so, ähm, ich bin damit super zufrieden, ja, die sind einen Ticken
breiter als so die Standard Gehäuse, aber nicht so viel, das ist aber nicht schlimm,
die kommen wirklich schön rein, ähm, die Lüfter, die Standard Models drin sind okay,
mit Staubfilter alles, kann sich nicht beschweren, ansonsten machen die Gehäuse einen super
Eindruck.
Mesh, was, Mesh-licious Gehäuse, case, Sus, was ist das für ein Hersteller, Subt, Subt,
Subt, da fängste dir aber ganz schön viel Staub ein, oder, wenn der so viel Löcher
hat, ne, das ist nix, das ist ja verstaubt nach zwei Wochen, oder du hast überall extra
nochmal Staubfilter dahinter, was jetzt aber nicht so aussah, so, was haben wir denn sonst
noch, also was wollte ich sonst noch gucken, was die haben, ach ja, wie siehts denn aus
mit Vera Gewindeschneider Set, was kostet das da aktuell, nix, ich dachte schon es gibt
einen neuen Toolcheck Plus, aber das ist schlicht und ergreifend eine Tasche für 25 Euro, Alter,
also, ey, ich mein die könnens auch übertreiben, so ein komisches Stück harte Plastikstoffmischung
mit einem Klettverschluss, 25 Euro, ja ist klar, ja, das teuer ist halt teuer, Toolcheck
ja, aber wir können mal gucken, ob es wieder welche gibt, also den kann ich wirklich empfehlen,
aber den gibt es nicht, ne, was gibt es denn an Werkzeug so aktuell da, haben die was,
nein, natürlich nicht, das gute Werkzeug gibt es natürlich nicht im Prime Early Access,
oder das Gehäuse aus dem Sail, Alter, sag mal, wie viel RGB willst du haben, das typische
YouTube Comment war jetzt, wie viel RGB willst du, ja, Alter, wie viele Styles gibts denn
hier vorn, bitte schön, Alter, es hört ja gar nicht mehr auf, man kann auch nicht rückwärts
gehen, weil procken, wenn man rückwärts geht, 35 Euro, und das hier 110 Euro, Leute, jetzt
das, mehr RGB, please, mal ganz davon abgesehen, das Gehäuse kommt wahrscheinlich noch nicht
mehr mit RGB-Lüftern, oder, das ist einfach nur Show, was ist denn Mars Gaming, hab ich
noch nie was von gehört, sind das China-Chinesen, MarsGaming.eu, noch nie gehört, Spectacular
and Creativity, ne, Moment, Moment, Moment, sorry, sorry, Spectacularism, ach du Scheiße,
was ein Wort, Spectacularism and Creativity without Limits, Mars Gaming, ok, Kontakt,
China-Chinesen, ja oder nein, Biomac SL, Biomac SL, in Spanien, das sind Spanier, oder,
Mars Gaming, keine China-Chinesen, Leute, wir haben den, wir haben den unrecht getan,
Spanier, Biomac SL, Mars Gaming, gibt's denn gescheites Werkzeug vielleicht, so in, müssen
wir mal gucken, Tools, hier, Tools, do it yourself und Tools, alles klar, zeig mal, gutes
Werkzeug kann man nie genug haben, das Problem ist, dass es meistens kein gutes Werkzeug
gibt bei Prime Days und sowas, meistens gibt es tatsächlich Bosch Akkuschrauber, der hab
ich auch rein von, die 12 Volt-Dinger sind wirklich sehr, sehr nice, gerade auch dieses
Set hier, da kannst du dich nicht beschweren, muss man sich ein bisschen überlegen, was
man haben möchte, es gibt, es gibt diesen kleinen mit, das ist gar nicht der, den ich
meine, gar nicht der, es gibt den kleinen mit Bohrfunktion, also mit so einem Schlagwerk
drin und ohne, ob man das haben will, ganz ehrlich, warum ist das jetzt auf einmal auf
italienisch, nee, da ist zu viel unsinniges Zeug dabei, wenn das Set ist mit zwei Akkus,
dann ist das ziemlich nice, weil zwei Akkus sind wirklich praktisch, da kannst du einen
benutzen und einen aufladen, das ist der GSL-12-2-L, haben die die Dinger umbenannt, die Dinger
nicht mal, nee, nee, GSR-12 hießen die schon immer, aber hießen die nicht mal, nee, GSR-15
hießen die doch sonst, gut, wie auch immer, die Teile sind wirklich nice, da hab ich schon
Dinger mitgebohrt und Schrauben reingedreht, da glaubt man gar nicht, dass man mit einem
12 Volt-Akkuschrauber dahin kommt, ich hab letztens, bei mir im Hof in die Wand, hab
ich, wartet mal, was war denn das, 10 mal 80 oder so, kann das sein, ja, die Dinger hab
ich letztens mit dem 12 Volt-Akkuschrauber in die Wand gehauen, 80, also 8 cm Schrauben,
ich glaub die 8 cm beziehen sich auf die, nee, das sind die Dübel, die schrauben sie
noch ein bisschen länger, Moment, das sind 8 mal 40, hä, wait a minute, ich denke das
sind 10 mal 80, ja, was ist es denn jetzt, nee, wat, keine Ahnung, zumindest, man glaubt
es gar nicht, die hab ich mit dem 12 Volt-Bosch-Akkuschrauber in die Wand gebohrt, also erst Loch gebohrt
in die Wand, dann die Dübel rein und dann die Schraube noch durchgedreht, noch ein
Stückchen weiter in die Wand, also, hätt ich gar nicht gedacht, aber das Ding hat wirklich
Power, oh das Bosch-Grill stellt uns den Akku vor, Akkuschrauber, ok, sehr nichtsagend,
also wer noch keinen hat, den kann ich wirklich empfehlen, für 90 Euro oder was das Set kostet
ist das wirklich sehr nice, also, wenn da 2 Akkus dabei sind, das wäre natürlich nice,
2 mal Akku, ja, das ist richtig, das ist gut, 2 mal Akku, ganz ehrlich, 1 mal Akku ist doof,
2 mal Akku ist nice, da kannst du im Zweifelsfall den einen auch schnell den Lader stöpseln
und weitermachen mit dem anderen, ja, du hast alles dabei, was du brauchst, du hast ein
paar Bits, du hast ein paar Bohrer, also das sind Holz und, wie nennt man das andere, Stein,
nee, Metall, nee, wie heißt das, Holzbohrer und Allzwergrestbohrer, keine Ahnung, wie
man das nennt, also das ist ein gutes Set, ja, und ich hab damit schon Dinge in die Wand
gekriegt, das hätt ich echt nicht gedacht, dass man das mit so nem kleinen Teil hinkriegt,
ist der 15er auch schon brushless, ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, also meiner
ist auf jeden Fall, den ich habe, der ist noch nicht brushless, weil der macht Funken
manchmal beim an und aus machen, was ja eigentlich ein Hinweis dafür ist, dass es kein brushless
Motor ist, also wenn man da reinguckt und es dunkel ist, dann sieht man das, ansonsten
hab ich keinen Plastenschimmer, zumindest bin ich damit, ich hab auch nicht die allerneueste
Ausgabe davon, die ist schon ein paar Jahre älter, aber ich muss sagen, bin ich wirklich
zufrieden von, bin ich wirklich zufrieden mit, also es ist wirklich sehr, sehr pog,
achja, und das Gute ist, wenn ihr euch andere Dinger von Bosch kauft, zum Beispiel irgendwie
ne Beleuchtung oder sowas in 12 Volt, dann könnt ihr die Akkus verwenden, leider kocht
leider jeder Hersteller so sein eigenes Süppchen, was Akkus angeht, müssten sie nicht, die
könnten ohne Probleme untereinander funktionieren, aber die passen halt nicht rein, weil die Hersteller
halt Vendor Login machen wollen.
Zeig mal kurz her, was haben wir hier, ein Professional Blower Gatchi Base, so ein Laubbläser
oder, hast du schon die Bosch Pfeffermühle für den Akkuschrauber, passt, nee, wusste
ich auch bis jetzt nicht, dass es die gibt, ich hab auch keinen Vera Flaschenöffner,
ich habe aber eine Nvidia Ente, beste, nicht Enterprise, Ente, aber eine Nvidia Ente hab
ich, das glaub ich auch ok, Professional Exclusive Digi, was ist, wofür ist denn das da, um zu
gucken ob Leitungen unter der Wand sind oder, ahja, jaja, ist es, und wofür ist dieser
Stift, der wird doch bestimmt nicht, der wird doch bestimmt nicht zum Malen sein, zum Anzeichnen
oder so, das ist doch bestimmt auch für irgendwas, dann hab ich schon was, es gibt sonst noch
so Sägeplätter, weitere Akkuschrauber, ist nicht sonderlich spannend, was ist das, Bosch
Professional, sehr gute Bezeichnung, ah das ist ein Entfernungsmesser, ok, Bosch Professional,
was hast du dir gekauft, ich hab mir gekauft Bosch Professional, was, nach was soll ich
suchen, Bosch Attachments, was, XO, ah die Pfeffermühle, das ist doch absichtlich gememt
oder, die meinen doch nicht wirklich, dass die da mit dem Akkuschrauber da steht und
lacht dabei, das ist doch Meme Faktor oder, oder meinen die das ernst, was haben wir denn
sonst noch, jetzt halt mal kurz, schnell Durchgang, ein ordentlicher Bohrer, da müsste ich nicht
mehr alles mit dem Akkuschrauber machen, obbei ich hab ja einen ordentlichen Bohrer, aber
ich bin immer zu faul den zu holen, ja also wenn man sich so eine Lampe kauft, passen
die gleichen Akkus rein wie vom Akkuschrauber, so eine Lampe hab ich auch, die ist äußerst
praktisch, kann man aufhängen hier oben an so einem Griff, kann man stehen, hinstellen
und hinlegen und machts nice hell, so im Keller zum Beispiel, wenn man da irgendwo was schrauben
muss oder irgendwas was machen will, so eine Lampe ist praktisch, ich hatte früher immer
so Kopflämpchen und sowas, kennt ja die, diese Stirnlampen, das ist vielleicht nice,
wenn man nachts, wenn man so krasser Outdoor-Vlogger ist und durch den Wald läuft, dann mögen
das vielleicht nice sein, wenn man so Stirnlampen hat, aber wenn man irgendwo was schrauben
will oder heimwerkern will, dann ist ein ordentliches Licht besser als irgendwelche komischen Stirnlämpchen.
Wo machst du den Akku dafür hin, ist das dann so ein extra Rucksack zum aufziehen oder?
So, mal schnell vollfahren, zack zack zack, was haben wir hier sonst wie, ach guck mal
Flexi, Flexi-Click oder wie das heißt, gibts auch hier einen, also mehr guck ich mir jetzt
dann, das reicht jetzt, was haben wir sonst noch an Tools zu bieten, Tools, wir wissen
ja alle, dass man Tools mit Z schreibt, genauso wie man Seriennummern auch mit Z schreibt
hinten, wer weiß der weiß, wer nicht weiß war früher nicht dabei, so was haben wir hier
sonst noch zu bieten, Staubsauger, ne das sind kein Staubsauger-Roboter, das sind Mäh-Roboter
oder sowas, Robotic Lawn Mower, Intelligent Navigation, die Sache ist die woher erkennt
er denn, bis wohin er fahren muss, woher weiß der oder rasen zu Ende ist, irgendwas zu verlegen
ist doch doof, aber Draht in der Wiese ist Paynes Champ, will denn sowas machen, außerdem
ist mein Garten viel zu uneben für sowas, aber gute Ladung Hochdruckreiniger, excellent,
haben wir sonst noch schönes, Prime Early Access, Eufy, China-Chinesen Kram wieder,
Anker, warum ein chinesischer Laden auf die Idee kommt sich Anker zu nennen, erschließt
ich mir eh nicht, Eufy Security Doorbell, ja wahrscheinlich mit Cloud-Unterstützung
und nicht funktionsfähig ohne Cloud, ein Handstaubsauger, der mäht auch gern den Draht durch, ja das
war natürlich doof, ich dachte den verbuddelt man, statt den Rasen-Roboter kann man auch,
ey, was meint ihr, wie das läuft bei meiner Mutter, die war schon öfters, die ist jetzt
71, die geht als Oma durch, die war schon öfters drüben beim Nachbar und hat das eine Nachbarkind
gefragt, wie sieht es aus und der mäht dann unseren Rasen manchmal, ich halte mich da
raus, sollen wir das mal machen, sonst will der noch Geld von mir haben oder so, das soll
die mal schön bezahlen, ja, so was haben wir denn sonst noch, ihr weiteres Werkzeug, ok
hier gibt es anscheinend nichts, China-Chinesen-Ader-Endhülsen-Pack, oder, ja sind welche, also wenn
man nicht Elektriker ist, ganz im Ernst, braucht man sein Leben lang nicht so viele Ader-Endhülsen,
wie hier drinnen sind, glaube ich habe mein gesamtes Leben drei Ader-Endhülsen gebraucht
oder so und ich weiß nicht, wie oft man welche als Elektriker braucht, aber da wahrscheinlich
öfters, China-Chinesen-Billig-Zang, Latex-Handschuhe, ja da habe ich schon drauf gewartet, ja unbedingt,
wieder China-Chinesen-Zeug, ein Duschkopf, aber warum nicht, gut da müssen wir nicht
weiter gucken, das ist relativ, relativ langweilig, gibt es denn irgendwie sowas wie Top Deals
oder, was sagt ihr, wie My Deals oder so, die haben ja meistens da ganz gute Übersicht,
gibt es irgendwo eine gute Übersicht, was Amazon gescheit das hat, Datsun, Alter, wer
will Datsun gucken, ne Datsun, ne was ist das überhaupt, ah das ist, das ist Audio-Streaming,
oder, ne, oder sind das die, die Fußball, ich blick nicht mal durch, ich konsumiere
das alles nicht, was ist Datsun Leute, Datsun ist Fußball, ok, ich dachte The Zone ist jetzt
Fußball, oder ist The Zone von Datsun, ach Datsun ist The Zone, ach so, Alter, wieder
sowas gelernt, Seste mal, hat sich schon wieder gelohnt den Stream einzuschalten heute, ok,
hat das mit Boomer zu tun, ich interessiere mich halt einfach null für Fußball, ok zeig
ich mal her, Amazon Deals, Asus TUF Gaming, ne, wer will denn das jetzt noch haben, wenn
schon will ich 2000 Euro für eine 4090 ausgeben, der Erbsen Raupe wusste das auch nicht, wussten
wahrscheinlich viele nicht, hier mit Equipper, Ultra Gear, ein iPad, ne, Hammer, zwei, brauchen
wir denn noch ein iPad, der Vera Werkzeug Adventskalender, das kann doch nix gescheites
sein, da ist dann irgendwie so ein billiges Zeug drin, oder ab und zu mal irgendwie ein
Torx Bit oder sowas, was man eh schon hat wenn man es braucht, ich meine der ganze Weihnachtskalender
ist wahrscheinlich, also in der Regel ist der Weihnachtskalender eh immer deutlich teurer
als das was drin ist, und wenn man sich überlegt, dass man Vera schon das Gewindeschneider Set
55 Euro kostet, das ist ein Gewindeschneider Bit Set, wenn irgendwie 6 Gewindeschneider
drin sind, schon 55 Euro kostet, da ist dann irgendwie so ein halber Schraubendreher drin
und das war's dann, Microsoft Xbox Series X Wireless Controller Carbon Black Xbox SX
und Xbox One PC, wer soll das richtig aussprechen, wisst ihr was ich gerne hätte, ein Xbox 360
Controller, ja ihr könnt so viel Boomer schreiben wie ihr wollt, aber ich mag den Xbox 360 Controller
lieber als jeden anderen Controller, Amazon kaputt, Xbox 360 Controller, das sind alles
nur irgendwelche Nachbauten und Fakes, die sind alle Müll, ich will ein Original haben
und die gibt's halt nicht mehr, guck mal du suchst ein Original und was findest du,
Text Row Controller, also ich finde Text Row und Microsoft kann man schon mal verwechseln,
finde ich auch noch nicht Text Row fast anders als Microsoft, aber es gibt keinen Original
Controller mehr, glücklicherweise hab ich noch zwei hier, Unterstützung für Dampfspiele,
oh nice, wenn man Steam halt Wortwörtlich übersetzt, die lecken richtig viel Critical
Information da, das ist der richtige, Official Xbox 360 Controller, was, Alter den muss
ich kaufen, nein das ist gebraucht, Moment das ist gebraucht, jaja Sekunde das ist nichts,
das ist nichts Offizielles, Rare and Common Items, das ist, das ist Fake, gebraucht, Openbox
ist gut, very good, ja, Chat gerne neun, Wire the Speed, es gab schon, Leute es gab schon
beknackte Gadgets für die Xbox oder, Leute zu viele Tabs offen jetzt ist vorbei, es gab
schon beknackte Gadgets für die Xbox oder, was auch immer das sein soll, ich sehe es,
es soll ein Lenkrad sein, aber naja, Marc Kischy Dankeschön für den Sub, aber wie gern
hätte ich einen neuen Wired, Xbox 360 Controller, Weird Champ, Wired Champ in dem Fall, ich
glaube das beste an den Pixel Handys ist, dass du relativ langes Support hast, ist doch
noch so oder, was ist denn mit dem neuen falsch, zum Beispiel, dass die Daumenauflage kleiner
ist und sich das Material für mich unangenehmer anfühlt, der neue Controller ist technisch
gesehen besser, keine Frage, der ist genauer, der hat weniger Dead Zones drauf, aber ich
mag den 360 Controller, echt, ja, aber im Zweifelsfall bekommst du für die Pixel noch
richtig lange irgendwelche, wie heißt der Kram, Cyanogen Mod und sowas, Custom, Custom
ja, also Lineage OS heißt es ja nicht Cyanogen Mod, das war ja mal vor 30 Jahren, ja, aber
es ging in dem Fall ja um das Google Pixel und für das kriegst du auf jeden Fall auch,
ja für iPhones gibt es lange, das weiß ich, ich hab ja selbst ein paar iPhones und iPads,
also das kann man Apple tatsächlich nicht vorwerfen, sogar das aller allererste iPhone
SE hat noch glaub ich letztes Jahr Updates bekommen, mittlerweile nicht mehr, so da ist
nix dabei, zu, zu, sag mal geht es noch jemand so, dass ihr das total unübersichtlich findet
bei Amazon, ich weiß gar nicht wo ich gucken soll, egal, schauen wir mal kurz hier auf die
Schnelle durch, jede Menge, jede Menge Grafikkarten brauchen wir nicht, SSDs brauchen wir, ich
kann mir doch jetzt 48 Seiten angucken, Alter, was ist da los, mein ganzer verdammt, das ist
doch gar nicht Amazon, das ist Saturn, wusste nicht, dass Saturn neuerdings bei Amazon verkauft,
ach nee, hier muss man einstellen auf Amazon, Fritzbox ohne ISDN, ah gut, das ist jetzt
glaub ich kein Problem, dass es kein ISDN mehr kann, wir haben in der Ausbildung noch
ISDN gemacht und es war damals schon Crap, also an sich rein für Telefoniefunktionen
und so war ISDN mal ne gute Idee, aber es hat halt keiner gebraucht letztendlich, hättet
ihr mal der Telekom das erzählt im Jahr 2000, dass ihr sagt, analoges Telefon überlebt
ISDN um Jahrzehnte, da hätten die gesagt, null Alter, ISDN ist die Zukunft, erzähl
kein Mist und 2022 ist es so, analoges Telefon alles nice, ISDN null ist weg, ich mein gut,
dass es im Backend heutzutage auch kein analoges Telefon mehr ist, das ist klar, das ist
alles IP, Backend technisch, wenn nicht sogar bis zu euch, ich mein ich verwende reines
IP Telefon bei mir mittlerweile, also intern nicht, intern ist es deckt, unten tatsächlich
noch ein analoges Telefon dran an der Fritzbox, aber ansonsten ist bei mir direkt VoIP, bei
Easybell, ich bin vor ein paar Jahren weg davon, ich mein egal wo du hingehst, ob jetzt
zur Telekom oder zu Vodafone, Telefon ist eigentlich immer dabei, aber ich hab absichtlich
mein Telefon umgezogen zu einem dritten Anbieter, dass ich meinen Internet Provider jederzeit
wechseln kann, ohne dass es irgendwelche Telefonnummern Portierungshickhack gibt, jetzt bezahle ich
2,90€ im Monat und ich telefoniere eh nicht großartig, also insofern, Easybell, hab ich
genommen für VoIP, ich bezahle 2,90€ oder so im Monat, nee nicht Internet und Telefon,
nur Telefon, nur Telefon, ach für zu Hause muss ich machen, nur Telefon, Achtung Flashbang,
tut weh, hier, das da, 2,99€ im Monat, fertig, 500 Minuten krieg ich eh nicht hin, ich hab
dort meine Telefonnummer und ich hab kein hin und her mehr bei der Rufnummernportierung,
es ist ein ganz normaler VoIP-Anbieter, trägste in einer Fritzbox ein und es hat halt den
Vorteil dadurch, dass es ein ordentlicher VoIP-Anbieter ist, dass du auch so Sachen
machen kannst wie mit nem VoIP-Kleid dich aufm Handy anrufen lassen und sowas, ist eigentlich
ganz nice, warum hast du noch Festnetz, ja gut, weil manche halt die Festnetznummer haben
und da anrufen, ja beispielsweise irgendwelche Behörden oder sowas, die haben halt noch Festnetz
und den will ich auch nicht, meine Handynummer geben, wo hast du Internet, ich habe Internet
bei Vodafone, ja von EasyBella hab ich tatsächlich auch noch gute Sachen gehört bisher, muss
doch mal Flashbang die Seite, kann man nicht gescheit sich angucken, egal Flashbang, oh
guys, wartet mal, wartet mal, wartet mal, leid, ok, ok, besser, so, so ist ok, so ist
in Ordnung, mal gucken, ob es wieder kaputt geht, wenn ich, ach hier geht das auf der
Seite, guck mal, das ist nur Amazon, was so procken ist, nur Amazon ist kaputt, ok, was
gibt es denn, Philips Hue, ich persönlich bin ja der Meinung, Philips Hue ist so eines
der überteuersten Smart Home Dinger, die man sich kaufen kann, ein Eufy, schon wieder
Anker, so viel Anker überall, China-Chinesen-Anker, Rasenmäh-Roboter, jetzt Anker unter Anker
und nicht mal Eufy, was soll denn das sein, ist das ein Solar-Panel, ein Solar-Panel und
ohne Batterie oder, würde ich jetzt mal, würde ich jetzt mal raten, der Dark Reader macht
voll den Abgang gerade, guckt euch das mal an, ein CPU-Kern, komplett dicht, Ring, gut
kommt mir auch nicht in die Tüte, noch mehr Anker, die haben schon abgedrehtes Zeug, da
erkenne ich auf dem Bild gar nicht was, ah wieder ein Solar-Panel, ok, Samsung Galaxy
Tab, nope, Android Tablets will ich auch nicht mehr, Android Smartphones kein Ding, aber
Android Tablets hat mich überhaupt nicht überzeugt, WLAN Powerline Adapter, ist das nicht irgendwie
ein Paradox, also WLAN Powerline, soll das sein, Sony RSRX, Bluetooth Speaker, Bose Noise
Cancelling Headphones, ja ich habe seit Jahren schon die Quiet Comfort von denen und damit
bin ich wirklich sehr zufrieden, ich habe nichts von Bose sonst, ich bin kein großer
Bose Fan, der einfach nur Bose kauft, weil Bose drauf steht oder Bose wie das die Amis
sagen, aber die Noise Cancelling, das Noise Cancelling Headset ist wirklich gut, Powerline
ist quasi Netzwerk über Stromnetz, ich weiß aber warum ist es dann aber WLAN Powerline,
das ist auch wieder irgendeine Batterie oder sowas, ich wüsste gar nie was, äh ja, Batterie,
Fingerabdruck Schloss, Videotürklänge, oh ne, das sind auch wieder so Dinger, die garantiert
nur mit der offiziellen App funktionieren, also erstens sieht das Ding, ja doch sieht
ganz ok aus, das ist so ein typisches Ding, was wahrscheinlich wieder nur mit der offiziellen
App funktioniert und wenn nur Login ohne Ende und kein Videostream abgreifen und nur
mit dem offiziellen Tablet Dashboard zu verwenden, IP Konflikt, schauen wir mal ob man den Stream
per RTSP abfragen kann, ich kann euch jetzt schon sagen, das geht nicht, API und RTSP
Anbindung wäre noch super, ja, und der einzige Grund warum es das nicht hat ist wenn nur
Login und Cloud Scheiße verkaufen wollen an die Leute, was sonst, ich mein es gibt
eigentlich keinen Grund das nicht einzubauen wenn man nicht die Leute gängeln will und
man will die Leute gängeln, deswegen kaufe ich den Scheiß nicht, so was haben wir dann
sonst noch, Fritzbox brauche ich nicht, ein Eve Energy Strip brauche ich auch nicht, ist
das eine Steckdosenleiste oder was, über was steuert man das, ist das Zigbee oder was
ist das oder auch wieder temporäres wenn nur Login, nicht RTMP, RTSP, ne zum Videostream
abfragen, 76 Euro ist mega teuer, warum wollen die da so viel Geld für und wie lässt man
und wie bedient man es, Apple HomeKit, es ist kein Zigbee, es ist WiFi und wahrscheinlich
noch nicht mal WiFi, dass man das irgendwo anders anbinden kann aus der Apple HomeKit,
schauen wir mal, Eve Energy Strip, erstmal gucken wir mal was das Motor flaschen kann,
nein natürlich nicht, gibt es eine Home Assistant Integration, ja gut über HomeKit, das ist
mir auch klar, tja, funktioniert wieder nicht richtig, smarte Wetterstation, wo ist denn
da die Wetterstation, ich sehe keine Wetterstation auf dem Bild, das ist keine Wetterstation,
es ist vielleicht ein Luftfeuchtigkeits- und Temperaturmessersensor, das ist keine Wetterstation,
wie will das Ding beispielsweise messen, wie viel Regen reinkommt, wie viel Wind, so bestimmt
nicht, das ist ein Temperatursensor, wahrscheinlich ein besserer Temperatursensor, ach Moment,
das musstet ihr alles selbst noch kaufen dabei oder was, naja, dann kann ich mir auch
eine China-Chinesen Wetterstation kaufen für 150 Euro und die ist besser und die ist genauso
wenig genau wie die, aber genau genug, also ich muss sagen, ich habe ja seit einer Weile
so eine Wetterstation im Hof hängen, das ist wirklich ganz praktisch, da haben wir
doch hier im Stream noch was programmiert, um das Dashboard ordentlich anzusprechen,
das ist wirklich ganz praktisch, das hat einen Sensor für, also erstmal hat es eine Batterie
drin und lädt automatisch auf, das ist schonmal gut, ich musste da nicht die Batterie wechseln
bisher, so, das hat einen Sensor für Windrichtung, Windgeschwindigkeit, Regen, Temperatur, Luftfeuchtigkeit,
also alles was dich so interessiert, bevor du aus dem Haus gehst und irgendwie hat 140
Euro gekostet, China-Chinesen-Station mit einem Display zur Anzeige und man kann es
den Home Assistant einbinden, die China-Wetterstation.
Heizkörper-Thermostat, da hatten wir es doch letztens erst von, Alter, der Scheiß ist
toll, hat es eine Home Assistant Integration, okay, es ist cloudbasiert, warum, warum muss
mein Heizungsthermostat cloudbasiert sein, was ein Shit, was für ein Internet of Shitshow
im Jahr 2022, ich will mein Heizungsthermostat nicht über die Cloud steuern, okay, was kostet
es denn, kostet es auch Abo, wir gucken jetzt einfach mal, würde das Abo kosten, kosten,
das ist richtig, die Hormatic-Dinger gehen ganz gut, also ich habe mittlerweile 4 Fritz-Dect-Thermostat,
die finde ich nice, ich habe ein paar ausprobiert und die haben am besten funktioniert, Hormatic
habe ich tatsächlich nicht ausprobiert, aber ich weiß, dass es da Integration gibt für,
let's keep heating affordable, ja, indem ich erstmal 203 Euro für 3 Thermostate ausgebe
und wahrscheinlich auch in Cloud, Ding, sehr affordable, okay, anscheinend gibt es zumindest
kein Cloud-Abo, das ist doch schon mal gut, das ist doch schon mal nicht verkehrt, ich
meine, immerhin versuchen sie hier keine Abos zu verkaufen, ja, ach man braucht da noch
eine Station für, na klar, irgendwie muss es ja empfangen werden, kann man, Moment,
gucken wir mal, Home Assistant without Cloud, es gibt ein Abo, echt, wo, ich sehe da nichts,
das zeigen sie hier gar nicht erst an oder was, ach so, man sieht das im Vorfeld gar
nicht, ah, nice, Tado, Subscription, zum Teufel, was ist das für ein, ach, was ist das
für ein, aha, wie es hier nirgendswo steht, 2,99 monatlich, 24,99 im Jahr, you can auto
assist, und was, was macht das, ist das KI, Machine Learning fürs Heizungsthermostat oder
was soll das sein, Alter, der Dark Reader macht, geht, so, Peace of Mind without Auto
Assist, ja, und was macht es, Energy IQ, was macht es denn jetzt, was ist es, was macht
es, ok, mit Geofencing, also sprich, dass man gucken kann, welche Gebiete man betritt,
ok, es ist quasi, Presence Detection mit einem Handy, ja geil, da will ich natürlich
unbedingt ein Abo für bezahlen, offene Fenstererkennung geht wahrscheinlich auch nur richtig gut im
Sensor, ansonsten, brauchen Thermostate, das liegt in der Natur der Sache, ein bisschen,
bisschen das checken, ne, anscheinend ohne Sensor, Moment, die Fenstererkennung ist hinter
einem Abo, wirklich, das ist ja, das ist ja mies, wenn die Fenstererkennung bei Thermostaten
funktioniert, so prinzipbedingt eh schon immer mit Verzögerung, ja, aber, dass das
hinter einem Abo ist, ist natürlich doof, ne, der misst ja nicht die Temperatur vom
Heizkörper, der misst ja die Temperatur, die Temperatur drumherum und wenn es da halt
schnell kühlt und die meistens sind die Dinger ja auch in der Nähe vom Fenster, aber trotzdem,
so sagen wir mal 10 Minuten oder 5, ne, 5 ist zu kurz, 10 Minuten brauchen die Dinger
trotzdem, bis sie das checken und bis dahin hast du das Fenster wahrscheinlich schon meistens
wieder zu, wenn du nur mal kurz lüftest, das einzige, wo das gut funktioniert ist ein Fenster,
Fenster Sensor, ja Abo, ne, ohne Cloud, ohne Cloud, ohne Cloud, lass mich raten,
ja ok, über HomeKit, über HomeKit, aber trotzdem und dann ist die Steuerung wahrscheinlich
trotzdem über die Cloud, ja geil, unsinnig, ne, das Abo bringt tatsächlich relativ wenig,
das liegt aber auch schon daran, bei mir würde es gar nichts bringen, weil es käme
mir nicht in die Tüte, ich sehe es nicht ein, dass ich meine Heizungsthermostate über
die Cloud bedienen sollte, das HomeMatic easy ist weiß ich, Akara, ja da müssen wir
mal gucken, na gut die Buttons brauche ich halt nicht, Drahtloserschalter H1, Moment,
was ist der Unterschied zwischen dem Minifunkschalter und dem Drahtlosen Schalter, ach das ist so
ein Ding, so ein Teil habe ich auch allerdings mit 6fach Knopf, das ist sehr praktisch,
Knopf auch hier Akara, Highspeed Click Mode, die Response Time liegt nicht so sehr an diesem
Schalter, sondern eher wie schnell das alles verarbeitet wird, dass die Reaktion sichtbar
ist, Gardinenmotor, ok, das habe ich noch nie probiert, ich überlege auch gerade wo
ich Gardinen habe, dass das was bringen würde, ich habe keine Gardinen, ich habe nirgendwo
Gardinen und Vorhänge, gibt es bei mir nicht Leute, ohne Scheiß, an keinem Fenster, ich
habe nix, da hängen, also brauche ich nicht, früher in meiner alten Wohnung wäre das geil
gewesen für den Duschvorhang oder sowas, da hätte ich dann den Duschvorhang automatisch
aufmachen können, wenn ich Fenster zum Lüften aufmache und so, aber ansonsten, das wäre
halt auch massiv unsinnig gewesen, aber nice, unsinnig, das ist alles, das ist aber echt
nicht so viel geiles, meine Güte Amazon, krieg dich doch mal wieder ein heute, so was,
wo können wir ansonsten gucken, Computer und Software haben wir schon geguckt, da war zum
größten Teil Müll dabei, so TV und Home Entertainment, Kitchen, Home und Furniture, schauen wir gleich
nochmal, Lightning Deals, ok, Deals unter 20, also was haben wir hier in Computer und
Software, Bildschirme, die ich nicht brauche, oh da fällt mir ein, ich muss ja mein Servicebook
immer noch installieren mit Arch by the Way Linux, habt ihr auch das Gefühl, dass Prime
Day jede Woche ist, ja es ist ja auch fast jede Woche was, es ist Cyber Monday, Black
Friday, Cyber Monday Week, Black Friday Week, Prime Early Access, Prime Week, Prime Day,
irgendwie, Ach das, Oster Sale, Weihnachts Sale, es ist laufend irgendwas, Cyber Monday,
ehh, hatte ich gerade schon, das ist das ganze Jahr über, oh man kann mit, man kann Azus
kann man safen, aber ich brauch von denen wahrscheinlich nix, ein Android Tablet, gibt
es so viel Schwachsinn, lass mich raten, wie der Anker, nein nicht Anker, sondern Bauir,
auch China-Chinesen Zeug oder, Bauir, das ist China-Chinesen Kram, erzählt mir nix
Leute, von wegen Instagram, guck mal die Seite ist fake, das gibt es alles nicht, Bauir-Block,
der Bauir-Block, WordPress, Hello World, WordPress, na das läuft ja wie FAQ, Contact Us, ok,
Anker, wie, Moment, reine China-Chinesen Sachen, die kommen aus London, was sind denn das für
eine Vorwahl, ist das England, ne oder, die Fahrschule, Eidl-Städtl, Städt, Pfff, die
Autos, Sos, der Sos, es ist wahrscheinlich am Ende irgendein China-Chinesen Ding, wenn
das so shady immer ist, ach ist das, 980, ach das hab ich gar nicht gesehen, guck mal,
das ist einfach, das ist mir gar nicht aufgefallen, 9876543210, das hab ich gar nicht gesehen,
lull, Three Head und das FAQ ist einfach umgedreht, das ist doch, das ist doch fake, Bauir, Leute,
ich, was zum, was lasert der das Auge, ach ne der will die Temperatur messen, ja ist klar,
dafür würde ich auch unbedingt Bau hier nehmen, das, das, weiß ich, das wirkt irgendwie nicht,
sondern ich vertrauenserweckend, 100 Meter USB, ach ne 100 Watt, 100 Meter wär mal geil
gewesen, das hätt ich gebraucht, 100 Watt weniger, demnächst Bauir Sponsor, Leute, ich
wurde angeschrieben von einem Mobile-Game, ob ich nicht, ob ich nicht möchte, ob ich
für die nicht ne Integration machen will, ich hab schon vergessen, wie das heißt, irgendein
Peggle-Klon ist, hab ich gesagt, jop, mach ich, ich bin eh der beste Peggle-Spieler,
lass uns Integration machen und dann haben die mir eine, ein Briefing geschickt, was
ich alles machen soll und unter anderem in dem Briefing stand, ich soll das Spiel runterladen
und mich selbst bzw. meine Hand dabei filmen, wie ich das Spiel spiele und begeistert davon
bin und sowas und da hab ich gesagt, ne, ne, ne, das machen wir nicht, die haben bestimmt
auch ne Wüste, ja, aber, also ich mach so Integration, allerdings nur wenn ich den Kram
nicht selbst spielen muss, wisst ihr, ich will den Kram weder runterladen noch will
ich mich damit auseinandersetzen, ich will einfach 60 Sekunden meinen Text runter rattern
und das wars, ich will das doch nicht selbst spielen, Mobile Crap, alter, nächstes kommt
noch der Coin Master oder sowas, Cool Master Sickle Flow, oder heißt es Cycle Flow, soll
es wahrscheinlich heißen, sieht billig aus, Anker, meine Güte gibt es irgendwas, irgendwas,
ok, da müssen wir jetzt nicht weiter, Netzwerkkabel, hui, pock, da hab ich auf Prime Day gewartet,
dass ich Netzwerkkabel kaufen kann, Shane, doch, Null, das ist ein Mikrofon, was super
professionell aussehen soll, wahrscheinlich billiger Kram ist, Alter, Moment, Sekunde,
das hab ich ja schon die letzten 15 Jahre nicht mehr gesehen diesen USB Anschluss, kennt
den überhaupt noch jemand von euch oder muss man dafür so alt sein wie ich, dass man diesen,
ich weiß gar nicht mehr wie das Ding heißt, USB A, ja, oder USB B, USB B kann sein, Excellent
Sound Quality glaube ich sofort, Professional Sound Chipset, es ist schon mal irritierend
wenn ein Mikrofon großartige Chipsets und so braucht, ein Mikrofon sollte eigentlich
ein gutes Mikrofon sein und kein guter, guter Aufnahmekomputer oder so, Alter, Wahnsinn,
McAfee man, dass es das überhaupt noch gibt, lebt der Typ, nee der Typ ist doch tot oder,
ist der nicht gestorben letztens McAfee, wurde er nicht irgendwo erschossen oder, Moment,
der Typ, der wurde doch, hier, der wurde doch letztens, ja, 23. Juni 2021, ist doch gar nicht
so weit, so lange her, ach nee, der wurde nicht erschossen, der war im Knast, hat sich
umgebracht, okay, dachte irgendwie, der wurde erschossen, aber der hätte mich bei ihm auch
nicht gewundert, Paint Shop Pro, Sachen von denen man denkt, die gibt es nicht mehr, tauchen
auf einmal wieder auf, McAfee Doku, das gucken wir heute aber nicht, 1,5 Stunden, what the
fuck, Alter, Fehlzeiten 2022, nur Lexwear, Fehlzeiten Standard, also anhand des Titels
hätte ich keine Ahnung, was es ist, Alter, es gibt so viel Software, wo man sich denkt,
die gibt es nicht mehr und auf einmal ist sie wieder da, ich meine, wer verwendet sowas,
gibt es wirklich jemand, der sowas verwendet zum Videos schneiden, Gott, warum, anscheinend
muss das immer noch genug Leute geben, die das kaufen, weil, das sind dann so Leute,
die sich auch irgendwelche Boxen kaufen mit CD's drinne, Acute Keyboard, Microsoft 365
Single, Winzip, sag mal, wo bin ich denn hier gelandet jetzt, Mensch, Winzip 26 Pro, was
kommt als nächstes, Winra, oder was, also ein Schnapper für 45 Euro Winzip, das gehört
auch Coral mittlerweile, wem gehört Coral, wollen wir gucken, ob es VLC kippt, VLC Videoplayer,
ne, gibt es nicht, aber nicht in Prime Deals, Moment, ne, gibt es nicht, aber bei, bei
Saturn oder so, wo wir letztens geguckt haben, da gab es Video, gab es VLC zu kaufen, ok,
das war nix dabei, was haben wir hier, Computer und Accessories, das haben wir schon geguckt,
oh, nice, bunte USB Kabel, nein, E, das sind bunte Lightning Kabel, das haben wir schon
geguckt, was haben wir hier, Computer, nochmal, kann das sein, dass Amazon keine Tabs unterstützt,
bin verwirrt, ok, Deals unter 20 Euro, jetzt die Schnapper schlechthin, hier ist, der Akkuschrauber
kostet 110 Euro, was heißt hier, Deals unter 20 Euro, die Kaffeemaschine kostet sicherlich
auch mehr als 20 Euro, Amazon ist, das ist, so weird Champ, alles, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ich meine, was, was will Amazon von mir, ok, weiter gehts, was haben wir als nächstes,
Lightning Deals, Unterhosen, na endlich mal was gescheites, tatsächlich das erste sinnvolle,
was, was ist das, das sieht zumindest auf den Blick irgendwie, what, grüne Erbsen, rote
Bo, Erdbeeren, was, warte mal, ach ne, das sind nur die Boxen, das sind nur die Boxen,
das hat, also das Bild hat mich jetzt verwirrt, mal ganz davon abgesehen, dass das wahrscheinlich
Photoshopped ist, aber sollte man das, sollte man das Zeug nicht kühlen, anstatt Erbsen
einzeln abzufüllen in Plastikdingern und neben Erdbeeren und Nüsse zu stellen, different
sizes, eher tight, ok Unterhosen gibt es, das ist doch schon mal was, ah der Endhülsen,
es gibt, ist das ein Laser Gravierer oder was soll das sein, ja tatsächlich, Leute,
damit haben die das geschnitten, damit haben die das geschnitten, ich wollte gerade sagen,
Laser Gravierer können nichts in Farbe machen und es gibt ne billige Brille, die dich davor
schützen soll, dass du blind wirst und DHL gibt es auch dabei, nice, noch mehr Unterhosen,
100 Kindertattoos, besser als richtig tätowieren lassen in dem Alter, ein Snack Spender, ja
wenig, das ist mal was Sinnvolles, da muss man dann seine, ok dann kriegen wir zumindest
die Hände nicht mehr fertig, das ist schon mal gut, aber jetzt nachdem ich so viel abgenommen
habe, ich will eigentlich gar kein Snack Spender, sonst mache ich den ganzen Progress wieder
zunichte von diesem Jahr, jetzt gibt es auch Unterhosen für Grillz, genau, muss ja auch
sein, Solar Panels, Schuhe, noch mehr Unterhosen, Schlafanzüge, es ist so, oh ein Oldschool,
Boomer Telefon Leute, GQdio, wobei so oldschool sieht das gar nicht aus, das wäre meinem Opa
definitiv schon zu modern gewesen, HD, guck mal das ist ein HD Telefon, kann man mit dem
Display irgendwas anfangen oder ist es einfach nur für die Optik, damit kann es bestimmt
kein Video Call machen, unsinnig, Schnurlos Telefon, beste, 100 Euro, ja die müssten
sie ja irgendwie rechtfertigen, das mit dem Display jetzt, Pipi Shell, das habe ich probiert,
sowas ähnliches habe ich mal für Chico gekauft, dann hat Chico Angst aufs Katzenklo zu gehen
wenn da sowas davor liegt, aber Chico hat vor allem gefühlt Angst, bei anderen Katzen
könnte es vielleicht funktionieren, bei meiner hat es nicht funktioniert, das 6 Minuten Tagebuch,
schön, das brauchen wir nicht, ich schreibe gar kein Tagebuch, auch nicht 6 Minuten, Tagebuch
ist auch so useless Geschichte, ich habe nie verstanden warum man Tagebuch schreiben sollte,
Unterlegmatte, Rucksack, Bubble Ruh, was für eine wilde Mischung aus unsinnigem Zeug,
ist das Filament für ein 3D Drucker, ja tatsächlich, Rash for Bash, ich habe keine Ahnung, was
Amazon mit diesen Dingern bezwecken will, das ist so viel und das meiste komplett useless,
unsinniger Kram, keine Ahnung, das waren jetzt auch nur die Lightning Deals, Celo ich wusste,
ich wusste, dass irgendjemand was schreibt dazu, als ich das Bild von der einen in dieser
engen Hose gesehen habe, wusste ich dann Chat mit irgendwas zu schreiben, ich habe einfach
mal weiter gescrollt gedacht, den hat bestimmt keiner gesehen, aber nein, war klar, es wurde
gleich gespottet von euch, manchmal hast du das Gefühl, dass das nicht war, ja ohne Scheiß,
also ganz im Ernst der Vergleich zwischen Aliexpress, wenn ich die Seite aufmache, da finde ich ja
bei Aliexpress mehr Zeug, was mich interessiert, als gerade bei Amazon, so was haben wir denn
hier, gibt es ja noch irgendwas spannender, die lustige Welt der Tiere, ja genau, das
habe ich gebraucht, das habe ich mit Chico jeden Tag, da gibt es jetzt ernsthaft Filme,
ich dachte, da gibt es irgendwie Projektor und Kabel und VGA-Halterungen oder so, was
interessiert mich, irgendwelche Oldschool-Filme, was ist das auf VHS oder so, vom Bild her
sieht es aus, ist das eine Videokassette oder ist das, ne das ist schon eine DVD, ok, ich
dachte, das sieht aus wie VHS, falls doch jemand weiß, was ich überhaupt meine, kennt jemand
noch Videokassetten, so diese Magnet-Dinger, die gerne verklebt sind, ja, gut, wenigstens
kennt ihr das noch, da bin ich noch nicht so alt, solange ihr das noch kennt, ist alles
gut, eine Güte, so viel unsinniger Krempel, den keinen Sau braucht, Betamax gab es auch,
weil das ging an mir vorbei, ich kenne nur Videokassetten, also ich kenne noch Audiokassetten,
Videokassetten, Schallplatten kenne ich schon nicht mehr, also ich kenne Schallplatten,
aber das war bei mir nicht mehr angesagt, also wo ich klein war, waren Kassetten so das
Mittel der Wahl, um irgendwas aufzunehmen und im Fernseher, also später Video, Videorekorder,
mit Videokassetten, da gab es dann diesen komischen Long-Range-Modus oder Extended-Modus,
der die Bildqualität runtergemacht hat, aber man hat irgendwie 6 Stunden oder so auf ein
Band gekriegt, High-End-Technology, ja Schallplatten sind tatsächlich wieder angesagt, habe ich
auch schon öfters gehört.
Für die Katze, ok, sollen wir mal bei Pets gucken, Amazon Basics, Pet-Bed, Chico legt
eh wo sie liegen will, wenn ich der da jetzt irgendwo in die Ecke legt, dann legt die sich
nicht drauf, Schallplattenbrenner, das müsste eher ein Schallplattenritzer sein, das wird
sich wahrscheinlich sogar verkaufen, Schallplatten-Scam-Video schon gesehen, du meinst, dass die Krise
der Audiophilen, meinst du das Video, ja ne, das habe ich nicht geguckt, das habe ich noch
offen in irgendeinem Tab, ok es gibt Kratzbäume, Chico hat einen Kratzbaum, den benutzt sie
aber nicht, die kratzt lieber beispielsweise an so einem Korb, kratzt er gerne rum, aber
da darfst du auch kratzen, Chico kratzt an allem, bloß nicht an ihrem Kratzbaum, das
war's schon, da wird Chico, für Chico aber nix dabei, nix, ups, what the fuck habe ich
da denn jetzt aufgemacht, nur Trash, nur Trash, oder wie XQC sagen würde, Trash,
auch wenn ich den schon seit irgendwie einem Jahr nicht mehr gucke, oder seit zwei, oder
keine Ahnung, seit der Chat so bescheuert geworden ist, dass du in einer Sekunde den
kompletten Chat durchgescrollt hast und seitdem es keinen Overwatch mehr gibt, wobei ich keinen
Overwatch mehr gucken würde, aber habe ich eine Zeit lang gerne geguckt, aber mittlerweile
ist mir das zu mainstream, kann ich mir nicht mehr geben, was noch nicht mal an ihm liegt,
das ist ja nicht viel anders wie früher die Streams, der Chat ist schon ewig bescheuert,
ja und ich mochte sogar, dass der Chat bescheuert ist, aber mittlerweile ist es ja einfach nur
noch ein reißender Strom an Text, der an dir vorbei fließt, also selbst wenn du was erkennen
willst, du kannst nichts erkennen, ist einfach nicht mehr das Richtige für mich, Chat es
ist wirklich nichts Gescheites dabei gewesen, wir haben eine Verteilerbox gefunden und eine
FV, die sich eventuell lohnt, nice, nice, das hat sich ja mal richtig gelohnt bei Amazon
reinzugucken, aber ich habe es euch ganz am Anfang im Stream gesagt, ich wette mit euch
es ist nichts Gescheites dabei und siehe da, es ist auch nichts Gescheites dabei, wer
hätte das sich nur denken können, Rust Late Night Stream, nee es schreit nach Max geht
ins Bett und schläft, damit er morgen um 7 Uhr aufstehen kann Stream, oh ich habe was
Neues bekommen, Sekunde, ein toller Kooperationsvorschlag für Max habe ich per Mail bekommen, zeig
mal her, da muss ich jetzt mal gucken, die sind auch ziemlich pepega, den habe ich schon
längst geantwortet bzw. nicht ich, what the fuck, vielleicht noch mal weiter, die ganzen
Marketingleute habe ich immer das Gefühl, die haben noch nicht verstanden wie Mails
funktionieren, ein toller Kooperationsvorschlag für Max, ja zeig mal her was wollt ihr denn
machen, ein Crossover zwischen Battle Royale, ob ich da so der Richtige für bin, da habe
ich so meine Zweifel, im Dezember ok, Integration Anfang des Videos, Link in der Beschreibung,
Link im Kommentarbereich, Dezember 2022, ja das mache ich solange ich es nicht selbst
spielen muss und ich erzählen kann, dass ich noch nie in einer Wüste gewesen bin, das
alles ok, das mache ich solange es ordentlich Stonks für gibt, ja morgen muss ich nach
Frankfurt fahren, korrekt, habe ich keinen Bock drauf, gar nicht so sehr wegen dort
wo ich hin muss, sondern wegen der Bahn und wegen Frankfurt, also es sind zwei Sachen
die Sacken, mit der Bahn fahren Sackt und Frankfurt an sich ist absolutes Drecksloch,
also vor allem im Hauptbahnhof und drum herum, ansonsten hat Frankfurt ja durchaus auch paar
nette Ecken, ja morgen wirds wieder schlimm, ich sag euch, bereitet euch ja Bahnflame Tweets
vor, Crackford ist kein Genuss, das stimmt, Frankfurt ist, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern,
einmal war ich beim Arzt, hat Blut ab, war Blut abnehmen, also bei meinem Hausarzt, das
wollte ich jetzt nochmal kurz erzählen, zum Thema Frankfurt ja, ich war bei meinem Hausarzt
Blut abnehmen und die haben mich gefragt, ob das der Azubi machen darf, die muss üben
und da habe ich gesagt, ah ja, sollst die Auszubildende mal üben an mir, also hat die
das geübt und da hat die nicht richtig drauf gedrückt beim Nadel rausziehen und das hat
schon übelst weh getan beim rausziehen und danach hatte ich so einen Bluterguss, den
kompletten Unterarm lang, Anzeige, Blödsinn, kann doch jeder können, ist ja Jailor wieder,
so und dann bin ich nach Frankfurt und auf einmal waren ganz viele Leute, wo ich so durch
das Bahnhofsviertel gelaufen bin, auf einmal so die, weißt du, es sind jetzt die ganzen
Leute, die immer auf irgendeiner Treppe gammeln oder in irgendeinem Hauseingang gammeln, die
waren alle total nett zu mir, als ich da vorbeigelaufen bin, die haben alle gesagt, ah hallo hallo
hallo ja, so und ich habe gesagt, was wollen die denn, was ist mit denen los, bis ich da
nachher gecheckt habe, ich hatte ein kurzärmliches Hemd an und die haben gesehen, mein Arm und
die haben sich gedacht, ich habe halt nicht richtig gespritzt und die haben vermutet,
wenn sie nett zu mir sind, gebe ich ihnen vielleicht was ab, Bruder, Bruder gibt, Bruder
gibt Stoff, das wird es gewesen sein, was anderes kann ich mir nicht erklären, ansonsten
reden die ja kein Wort mit einem, außer, außer dass man irgendwie von der Seite irgendwas
hört, letztens auch wieder gelaufen zum Südbahnhof, ja, irgendein Typ eiert vor mir rum, ich will
den links überholen, also zu Fuß, zu Fuß, ja und auf einmal, wo ich so zu Fuß, zu Fuß
überholt man Leute halt nicht superschnell, sondern läuft halt ein bisschen schneller,
dann den vorbei, auf einmal bleibt der Typ, der Typ abrupt stehen, während ich ihn überholen
will und taumelt rückwärts und macht dabei, und ich denke so, Alter, fuck man, wo bist
du hier wieder gelandet, Frankfurt ist halt abartig, was das angeht, was auch relativ
beliebt ist, ich weiß nicht welche Drogen das auslösen, aber wenn ihr mal nach Frankfurt
geht, achtet mal drauf, da gibt es relativ häufig Leute, also Drogenabhängige oder Verrückte,
die wie so Flugzeuge durch die Straßen laufen, die haben dann so die Ärme ausgebreitet
und laufen dann so die Straße lang, also nicht zu verwechseln mit so einer Hutu Running,
da machst du die Ärme nach hinten, sondern so Flugzeugmäßig die Ärme ausgebreitet
und manche machen dabei dann auch noch zzzzzzzzzzzz, kein Spaß Leute, das ist gestört, Typos,
genau, Typos und Flugzeug die Straße lang fliegen, man, hast du da nie Angst, dass
da einer mit dem Messer rumläuft, da muss, ob ich Angst habe oder nicht, da laufen ganz
viele mit messer rum das ist nicht die frage ob da einer mit messer rum läuft
sondern wer da fast nicht mit messer rum läuft in der ecke die haben wahrscheinlich fast alle messer
dabei wobei die ganz fertigen torenabhängigen nicht nein aber da gibt es bestimmt bestimmt ist
der anteil dort in diesen ecken mit also messer ist wahrscheinlich bei 40 50 prozent oder so
muss ich mal überlegen die mussten da jetzt schon in der einen an der einen straßenecke
in privaten sicherheitsdienst hin hin hinstellen weil die polizei nicht mehr oft genug kommen kann
für den also die polizei kam nicht oft genug mehr dahin weil die anderes zu tun haben aber
sie hätten öfters kommen müssen das ging so weit dass die friseur läden dort privaten
sicherheitsdienst engagieren mussten dass die leute sich überhaupt noch trauen in den friseur
rein zu gehen muss ich mir vorstellen ihr seid friseur laden und ihr müsst euch security vor
die tür stellen dass die leute sich noch trauen in euren friseur zu gehen also da durch zu gehen
durch die eingericht er frankfurt ist schon wirklich absolutes kacke wirklich dreckes loch man
dir passiert das ist richtig dir passiert meistens nix dir passiert die stechen sich untereinander
ab und schlagen sich untereinander unsere meistens passiert dir nix wenn du da so als unbeteiligter
durchläuft du musst die leute tatsächlich einfach ignorieren aber frankfurt ist wirklich
dreckes loch ganz ehrlich das ist gerade hauptbahnhof und die paar straßen drumherum so richtig richtig
getto mittlerweile war es früher auch schon war es eigentlich schon immer naja gut
also ich kann mich das fällt mir fällt mir jetzt gerade noch einfach also ganz abgedreht war es
mal wo einer von der brücke springen wollte ich bin ich bin auch gerade mittags heim gelaufen zum
südbahnhof laufe über die brücke diese und was ist sie unter meinen brücke ist das glaube ich
also die kleinere und gucke ich so nah ich denke nichts böses bin so mitten auf der brücke guck
so nach links und auf einmal steht da so ein typ hinter der absperrung und will von der brücke
springen ich denke mir so was machst du jetzt was machst du jetzt machst du jetzt was da habe
ich mich dazu entschieden ich mache nix ich gehe einfach weiter aber ich habe immerhin die polizei
auf twitter angeschrieben ich habe ich habe pepo lief gemacht ja ich bin weiter gelaufen ich
habe aber die polizei auf twitter angeschrieben habe gesagt hier auf der brücke da steht ein
typ hinter der absperrung rum und da haben sie geantwortet haben gesagt ist schon bekannt
die polizei frankfurt ist auf twitter sehr aktiv
glitter die haben dort die haben dort den ganz dach jemanden sitzen der das der das auch liest
was die leute schreiben die sind den ganzen dach am start hier polizei frankfurt
wollten einfach in den kaufhaus ausraum hat aber nicht so gut funktioniert anscheinend
die nestor bell willst du nicht haben alles cloud basierte ist müll willst
doch kein cloud service haben nur dass deine türklingel richtig funktioniert
rodo frodo dankeschön für den primes ab
jetzt mal kurz schnell ich habe nämlich glaube ich würde alle übersehen heute
makischi dankeschön für den sab dich habe ich glaube ich gesehen nanne 14
das habe ich gar nicht gesehen hat subscrib vor zwei stunden wie bildest du dich weiter
und was würdest du jemandem fehlen der nicht wirklich viel in seiner ausbildung mitnehmen
konnte weil betrieb so naja sind noch da nanne 14 wahrscheinlich nicht
ok wenn es schon deine selbst message war muss ich dazu natürlich auch noch was sagen also
wie bildest du dich weiter das würdest du jemand empfehlen der nicht wirklich viel in
seiner ausbildung mitnehmen konnte weil der betrieb so naja also wie ich mich weiterbild
ist relativ einfach ich mache sachen die mich interessieren und mich interessieren
halt glücklicherweise sachen die auch für meinen beruf relevant sind das ist natürlich
nice ich meine musste ja einfach nur die letzten streams angucken wo wir sachen gebastelt haben
oder cloud geschichten konfiguriert haben und sonst was da lernt man was bei und ich
interessiere mich privat halt auch für solche sachen die später mal also durchaus relevant
werden können das heißt das ist bei mir kein problem ich bin immer relativ auf dem aktuellen
stand einfach weil es mich interessiert das ist auch das was ich jedem empfehlen kann
also guckt euch die sachen halt an man man kann halt nicht sich darauf verlassen dass
man nur durch das was man auf der arbeit macht auf dem aktuellen stand bleibt weil wer soll
die arbeit auf den aktuellen stand bringen ist ja das so ein bisschen hände ei problem
also das das einzige und wichtigste ist wirklich dass man sich dafür interessiert und dementsprechend
auch das für einen kein ja keine anstrengung ist sich mit neuen neuen themen auseinander
zu setzen ja ich gucke mir teilweise abends im bett noch irgendwelche konferenztalks oder
so an eine halbe stunde mit interessanten sachen oder halbe stunde 45 minuten je nachdem
ich einpenne also es gibt eine weed konf ich dachte es gibt eine view konf es gibt es auch
eine weed konf aha wusste ich nicht was gibt korrekt home assistant so wenig klaut wie
möglich das beste was man machen kann aber es muss nicht home assistant sein aber es
muss so wenig klaut wie nötig am besten gar keine klaut ansonsten was kann ich ansonsten
noch großartig empfehlen ich mein wenn es jetzt um konkrete sachen gibt konkrete sachen
geht konferenztalks auf youtube sind nice wenn man auf dem aktuellen stand bleiben
will für neue themen gibt es auch jede menge tutorials auf youtube wenn es mal nix gibt
gibt es vielleicht irgendwo einen kurs ansonsten regelmäßig hacker news lesen man kann auch
heise und golem gucken wenn man auf deutsche seiten steht reddit die passenden subreddits
immer mal so rumgucken was so aktuell passiert kaufst du fachbücher oder sowas also ich
habe ein ct aber auch seit 15 jahren oder so oder schon länger glaube ich bin seit 20
jahren oder so 20 jahre ct abonnent ich lese die ct aber nicht mehr ich habe das abo nur
immer noch die liegen bei mir jetzt im bad und ich gucke die ab und zu vom klo aus an
aber ich gucke eigentlich nicht rein weil ich um klo immer aufs handy kucke wirst du
eigentlich nicht mit dem auto zu arbeiten ach wieso damit ich mich weiter über die bahn
aufregen kann ne es ist auch nicht besser da muss ich morgens nach frankfurt fahren
dort in der innenstadt habe ich keinen parkplatz bei uns das muss ins parkhaus fahren da muss
ich vom parkhaus ein stück laufen was dann von der entfernung ja gar nicht so der große
unterschied ist zwischen wie vom willi brandplatz laufen auf die arbeit anstatt vom ich stelle
es mir ehrlich gesagt auch wenn die bahn ein riesengroßer haufe haufen an ja setze beliebige
beleidigung ein ist ich glaube nicht dass es mit dem auto besser wäre ich kann halt direkt
von der haustür fahren zum südbahnhof das ist sehr praktisch wenn es geht ist das toll
aber es geht dann leider zu oft nicht wieso kein homeoffice mehr ich habe nur homeoffice
ich muss aber ab und zu nach frankfurt was hat der chain law wieder geschrieben dass
es jetzt gelöscht wurde was hat er angestellt nicht klicken aha aha ich weiß schon warum
du überall gebannt bist wahrscheinlich wegen solchen dingen aber wir bannen dich nicht
ich mag den chain law der hat auch schon schöne emotes gemacht aber manchmal geht es mit ihm
durch ja ja wenn du parkplatz hast wenn ich bei uns in die tiefgarage fahren könnte würde
das auch anders aussehen ok also leute ok da sage ich noch was zu gute einstieg in homos
ist also nachdem man das aufgesetzt hat und die ersten geräte integrieren möchte findet
er einfach keine anfangen naja du musst dir überlegen was du denn in deinem heim am besten
automatisieren bzw integrieren willst mit was willst du anfangen mit homos ist das alleine
bringt ja nix ja fange an fange mit irgendwas an was sinnvoll ist was dir was bringt ja
verspätungsanzeige für den zug fenster tür sensoren finde ich persönlich ganz praktisch
am anfang da sieht man immer wenn man was vergessen hat und kann sich dann ein nachricht
schicken lassen so nach dem motto hey du verlässt das haus und du hast vergessen das fenster
dazu zu machen recht hat ein auto eine integrieren integration dass du von einem auto was auslesen
kannst du musst du gucken halt was dir was bringt licht kann man machen wobei ich persönlich
licht relativ overrated finde doch der hau mich blau dankeschön vier monate subscription
massiv cute sup ok leute aber ich muss jetzt wirklich ins bett wir sehen uns im nächsten